Worst.
You know the Tommy Buns is here.
When you start getting tweets that say my jeans are high and tight and I'm
ready.
If anybody ever started saying calling each other mommies or saying genes are
high and tight,
we'd have to drive their fucking house and beat their ass.
Said you mean you want to talk about like a niche that you guys have carved out?
Yeah.
Jeans high and tight.
I know it feels silly even saying it sometimes.
Like when I say it I'm like,
this sounds so crazy,
but that's your show though in the show.
It's fucking silly shit man.
Your mom's house,
if you haven't heard it,
it's hilarious.
It's an awesome podcast and now you guys have a real studio now.
Yeah,
we finally,
we moved out of our house and got a proper proper studio and a proper office
building with real professionals who are like,
who the fuck are you?
It's just like what's happening to podcast meant slowly but surely podcasts are
being forced to be more and more professional.
It's crazy,
right?
So weird.
I walk out,
we walk out of our studio door in this really nice building.
There's an accountant to the right,
a lawyer across from me and a shrink to the left and it's like,
and they're like,
what are you guys do?
I'm like,
just farts and stuff.
Do you ever do you guys screen?
Yeah,
but here's the thing.
We go,
they also are like,
when are you,
like,
what kind of front is this?
Because we're there,
you know,
a couple times a week for a couple of hours.
We're never there.
So when they do see us,
they're like,
oh yeah,
you guys like,
you know,
yeah,
we scream sometimes and we don't go check on people.
But we assumed that they're like,
we don't want to know.
So do you swear like when you screamed you sweat?
Like you fucking bitch must,
right?
Sometimes you get crazy.
It gets crazy.
Yeah.
Sometimes it gets pretty loud and um,
at certainly offensive to them.
I mean for like those regular nine to fivers way,
they think that's normal.
A lot of them are listening right now.
People in those kind of offices are listening.
Oh yeah,
that shit is soul sucking.
It is.
I talk about it sometimes that,
do you remember,
did you ever do a an office office job?
No.
I never did an office office job.
I had a job jobs,
but never in an office.
You know,
I had a lot of,
I just knew,
I just knew from the time was whether whatever it is,
add or whatever the fuck it is.
I knew there was something wrong with my brain.
I was like,
there's no way or something right with it.
I knew there's no way I'm ever going to be able to sit in an office.
I just can't do it.
Yeah.
I mean,
I think back to when I did it,
I did it for a while at different places and I realize now looking back on that,
how depressed I was.
It was horrible.
It was really depressing.
And sometimes now when I'm don't feel like doing something like for,
for my career now,
like I'm bummed out to go do something,
you know,
like,
uh,
I dunno.
Press or more than radiation.
Yeah.
Morning radio or some morning TV.
Oh,
way worse than morning radio,
way worse,
way worse.
It's the worst.
But when I think of that,
sometimes I'll remind myself like,
oh,
remember that the real job that you had to do,
you know,
and s and sitting in that cubicle and how it really was misery for me.
Yeah.
And I imagine it is for a lot of people still.
I did Labor,
I did a lot of construction gigs.
My Step Dad's an architect and so I got a lot of gigs on construction column
gigs,
jobs on construction sites.
But the worst one I ever got was from my buddy Jimmy.
He got me a job.
Uh,
we were,
uh,
building a knights of Columbus Hall and uh,
we had to build a wheelchair ramp for it.
That's what we're,
we're doing.
And it was just the entire time I was working for them.
I only think I,
last two weeks I was carrying cement and pressure treated lumber.
So I was getting splinters in my fingers from pressure treated lumber and
carrying bags of cement.
And then at the end of the day,
I would try to go work out.
I go to the gym and try to work out collapsed.
I was so tired and Pulitzer wasn't hydrating correctly.
Horse and I,
you know,
I was an idiot back then.
I was eating like fucking Pastrami sandwiches for lunch.
Like I wasn't eating healthy all the time.
Well I do too,
but I mean when you're working all day like you know is the eating,
healing yourself throughout the day.
You should,
if you're doing that kind of labor,
the amount of calories that you're burning by carrying lumber and sandbags,
cement bags,
terrible.
It's exhausting.
I remember my first first ever job was construction where it was,
I was a freshman in high school.
It was the summer after freshman year,
so I'm 14 that's how end illegal you not even supposed to be working.
Well here's the job.
My,
my friend's dad,
but really,
really shitty apartment complex and was renovating it to make it like decent.
So he hired us because we were like slave labor,
like free basically giving us,
you know,
whatever the regular rate is.
It's half of that.
But you're the 1415,
so you're like,
yeah,
it's a shit load of money.
Right.
And we were in Florida in the summer in apartments with no AC.
Oh uh,
laying tile.
So you're on your hands and knees,
you know,
putting the grout,
laying the tile and just the heat was cooking it.
It was an oven,
you know,
like a hundred percent humidity,
96 degrees outside on your hands and knees sweat,
just pools of sweat and then some like actual constructive way stop sweating.
You're like,
I can't,
like I would tell you to stop because you're like,
you're cleaning like there you're,
you're getting to sweat in the,
in the grout and shit.
So then they'd come by three with towel to clean up your sweat as you're laying
tile on the ground.
I had a summer job where I was putting insulation in walls and attics in the
summer and so you're sweating like ass in Massachusetts.
It's hot and muggy.
You're sweating like a fucking pig and that shit gets in your skin.
It had like literally the fibers from insulation we get in your skin like you
just,
you,
it gets in your clothes,
it gets your,
your neck for some reason I can tracks it.
Like it will be always be like in here,
just your breathing it in you where those little stupid masks.
But those things don't do Jack Shit.
No,
those little,
I mean they might keep like a large particles from getting sucked right into
your trap.
But they come in the sides it,
you're breathing in air.
It's like,
or but if you could look at them unlike some sort of an infrared scan and see
the particles coming in and out,
like you're taking that stuff in your lungs.
Imagine the guy that does that for 40 years.
Oh it does to him.
You know,
it's really freaky man.
People that work in coal mines.
Have you ever watched,
they had a reality show for awhile about coal mines,
but I think they probably realized,
hey,
we better fucking not have this cause someone's going to die while we're
filming.
Yeah.
And then people are gonna,
you know,
be mad at us for making the show,
but they do live shorter lives.
Right?
They all hundred percent.
They get black lung,
they literally get black lung.
I mean,
you are 100% going to breathe in coal dust all day.
You're in a mine,
you're in a hole in the ground where they're digging and they're pulling out
coal.
I mean,
that's fucking nutty,
man.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's real.
It's really depressing to think about that.
That's that,
that's what you're doing every day.
And he'll like West Virginia and all these like really,
really poor places where they have these minds,
they get pissed when city people want to come in and shut down the mines.
Yeah.
Um,
Sturgill Simpson,
do you know who he is?
Country Music Star.
I know the name,
but brilliant,
brilliant singer,
but awesome.
Awesome.
Due to,
um,
the from there,
he's a,
yeah.
And um,
he has a song about it,
you know,
he has a song about I'm king.
It's all,
I think it's called King Cole.
It's so depressing.
But it's part of it is like that people from the cities come in,
they want to shut the mines down.
Like he,
and he was describing it to me.
He was like,
you,
you never seen poverty like this.
He's like,
it's just like these people don't have nothing.
Like in the song he talks about just welfare and pills,
but that's,
you ever see the wild and wonderful whites of West Virginia whole believable.
That's what it's like.
If somebody,
if you've never seen this,
it's so worth theme might be the greatest white people documentary of all
it is.
It is.
It's,
it's it,
it goes toe to toe with any and like and Freddy white person that like talks
trash about like other races and like,
well you know,
we're just different watch the wonderful whites.
West Virginia.
Yeah.
Anybody who thinks that white people are different than anybody else.
This is what people are people are,
is extremely malleable thinking organisms that adapt to their environment and
when you're in dire environment is all criminals and pills and welfare and
scams.
You just like,
I think you just grow up in that environment.
That's,
that's who you are and it shows that you really are a product of fuck.
Yeah.
That whole family is just,
it's unbelievable how they're all,
they really are the same,
the same organism,
you know,
they're like this,
all these different people,
they're from the same family in the same area and there is no like one that's
got it together.
It's like,
it's my favorite is a girl.
Hello,
my name is sue sue.
Bob Sue Bob,
the sexy
one.
Olive been a sag.
She in the family,
the,
there was a there.
They're kind of like running through the beats at the beginning.
Yeah.
I love that.
One of them is like talking about,
uh,
pills and she's like,
I think she's got like Xanax and she was like,
pick these up for like two bucks.
And she's like,
I'm run over here and sell for six.
It's a little boot scooting boogie Riley.
I was like,
her profit margin is a four bucks and she's thrilled about it.
Yeah.
The one check,
the way she talks,
she knit black gay is like,
you can't believe that she's a real person.
That's her right there.
You're doing a toned down version of sexy swine of fam.
See if he can fire her voice.
Jamie.
Because like when you hear a talk you like,
get the fuck Outta here.
That's not a real person.
Yeah,
always been.
It's sexy smile in the family.
Oh,
so,
but you know,
I used to have a buddy that when I lived in,
um,
it's going to be her.
Yeah.
Uh,
I got to hear this.
She's
her back then when I was saved at 18,
19 years old and he's somebody,
I'd probably say 10 to $2,000 a night.
And uh,
I'm always been a sexist one.
They look tired,
man.
I ones that time,
thousands of paper,
good documentary.
It's really great.
I had his buddy who was a,
when I lived in New York who's racist and a,
he's a good dude,
but he would say shit about black people.
I always get really mad at him.
We always had disagreements about race and he would go,
look,
he goes,
it's not racist if,
if it's everywhere you look,
he goes,
if it,
you see,
he goes,
it's just being honest about what you're saying.
I said,
no,
because if you grew up in that environment,
you would be them.
You dumb mother fucker.
Like you think you're something special just because you,
you grew up in Westchester County.
Yeah.
In some nice white neighborhood.
You know,
like all your problems.
You attribute all your problems because he had problems,
but he would attribute all his problems to his family and his fucked up
upbringing.
I'm like,
well,
think about your problems and your,
how mild you're fucked up.
Sadness was compared to these people that live in Harlem.
Yeah.
Are these people that live in the boogie down in the South Bronx that you're oh
shit.
Not like,
yeah,
dude,
if you grew up in that environment,
you wouldn't be special.
You wouldn't stand out as being this guy who gets it together and it's showing
up for work every day and he'd be smoking crack just like them.
Yeah.
You'd be doing things.
But we are a product of our environment.
Well it's like people,
they don't think that,
uh,
how they don't think about how lucky they are just to be born somewhere in a
certain circumstance.
Yeah.
I mean like I was shooting this,
uh,
shooting the intro to my new special we're shooting log,
we shouldn't like a one minute like short that that plays right before the
special,
you know,
like a little sketch basically.
And we were shooting it all over la and we ended up in
uh,
east La and Ramona gardens and the hazard projects.
This shit is no joke.
Right.
And as were there,
I was like,
just thinking about like,
man,
like cause all these kids came up to us because they saw the,
you know,
the cameras and the equipment,
the boom and all that.
And they were like,
they were just interested in what we were doing when they were young kid.
I mean they're teenage kids.
I just couldn't help but think about like,
man,
like this,
this funny thing that I,
cause it's still considered Los Angeles.
I was like,
when you say la to these kids,
this is what they think it is.
This is la to them.
Like the projects here,
they don't think of La as Bell Hollywood or Bel Air or,
or you know,
Malibu.
Like everyone's perspective on what that is,
is dependent on where you're from and you brought up like,
they have a really rough neighborhood man.
Really rough.
Like that's Mexican mafia,
you know,
cartel kind of shit.
Like,
you know,
it's face tattoos.
Oh fuck yeah.
A lot men a lot.
It's scary shit.
And,
and,
and those kids were just born there.
You know,
you just get a shit,
roll the dice.
Yeah.
You go to school with all those crazy kids that are dealing with whatever they
had to deal with when they're growing up.
Yeah.
Man,
there's,
there's a real problem in our culture where,
uh,
that doesn't get addressed.
Like when you hear Donald Trump on TV talking about Mexicans coming over here,
they're all rapists and murderers.
Hey Dude,
we got plenty of rapists and murderers right here.
Yeah.
And then some of them,
I assume are good people.
Yeah.
This is,
I assume some of them,
some of them,
but the idea that nobody ever talks about like what a real issue that it was
like nobody or people will lay out like problems,
tax problems.
Like they'll lay out like,
here's the problem with taxes in this country and this is my plan and I want to
institute a flat tax.
I don't want to do this and don't do that.
But nobody ever goes like,
these are kids that are growing up in these environments that are fucked and
they're there.
The burden that they have is so much more than the burden that someone has if
they're growing up in Pasadena.
Oh yeah.
You know,
extreme poverty's,
that's a real,
it's a real,
real issue that affects a lot more people and we have it in this country.
Oh yeah.
People always think of it as,
you know,
cause it is,
more extreme,
let's say in other places.
But there's a lot,
there's millions of people as countries that live in extreme below the poverty
line.
Yeah.
And yearly income.
The cost of living is higher here.
So like if you compare the extreme poverty here compared to the extreme poverty
in Bangladesh.
Yeah,
yeah.
I'm sure Bangladesh has more extreme poverty and it's probably more extreme even
in the context of like even if you look at the cost of living.
Yeah.
But it's,
it's still no excuse.
It's like there's,
there's no thought at all about trying to fix those issues.
Right?
Yeah.
People yet they're not,
it's not on their mind.
It's fucked man.
Cause think about it like how much time do you,
have you ever met someone who had a fucked up childhood and you go,
man,
if you could just get out of your own way and you can just figure out how to get
out of your own way and deal with all the shit that has messed you up up until
this point you'd,
you'd have so much more opportunity.
You'd have so much more.
You would get things done more.
Sometimes they didn't even have a fucked up childhood.
You just meet them and you're like,
get out of your own way.
Like it's all your,
your putting the obstacles in front of yourself.
Right.
I think a big problem with a lot of people have it in different facets of life.
It's just denial,
you know?
Yes.
And I was a big thing.
People live in denial about any number of things I can live with about,
about,
you know,
jobs,
about money,
about looks,
about weight,
about sex,
about everything.
But like that did not,
you can really,
you can sink into it and live in it for decades.
You'll live your whole life in denial.
Some people like that a lot.
Yeah,
you don't,
if you don't want to look at what you're doing wrong,
you don't want to look at what you need to clean up and it's really,
it's really that they're scared of the feelings.
Sure.
It's just a fear of like,
if I face that,
what will that be like?
And I think the reality is most of the time when you do,
it's not as bad as you thought.
It's the fear of that feeling is worse than the feeling itself.
Well,
the feeling,
even if it does suck,
once you get over it,
the feeling of overcoming that is so much better than the feeling of just
dealing with it and putting it in the box.
Yeah,
true.
You know the people that,
people that are ignore reality or hide from reality that you,
you were only going to get so far with that you're only going to,
you're always going to have those boundaries up that you can't overcome because
you've put them up to protect yourself from the truth.
And part of what it is about being a person when you're trying to get better at
something,
you gotta be able to look at the truth and you have to be.
Yeah.
And if you,
if you don't look at the truth in certain aspects of your life,
that's going to creep into the other aspects of your life too.
Yeah.
It's,
it's like the whole thing of,
you know,
being organized at your desk is going to spill out to your yeah.
To your house and your car.
And you know what I mean?
Like you do one thing right.
It will,
it will spill out to the rest.
And if you do things wrong,
it'll spill out to yeah,
there was a,
the old saying the gym like live every minute like a champion.
Do,
do your homework like a champion.
Do you know what,
whatever chores you have to do,
do that like a champion and you will be a champion in everything you do.
Be a champion in everything you do in life.
But I'm not,
I'm not doing that.
My office is a mess.
Well it's hard.
It's hard to do that.
Everything fucking problem right now.
I should make a video just to shame myself of my office because I get these
packages is boxes of shit that people send me in that company send me and they
fucking stack up to my office.
I sure my house looks clean cause you know I have a wife.
Yeah,
she's organized and stuff,
but my office looks like I'm a fucking hoarder.
My office was my whole house.
He'd be like cheese.
Yeah.
This weekend though.
All right.
I've got home.
I put,
uh,
I put a dent in it Thursday and another Denton and on Sunday I got rid of a lot
of shit.
It's crazy.
I feel like someone sneaks into my place and puts it there.
Cause I gave,
I did like a filled up eight trash bags,
like big ones of just clothes and shit and cords,
papers and then like it was like a week or two later I'm like where'd all this
shit comes?
Like there's new shit.
I feel like I haven't bought it or anything.
It's just spilling out of places.
I have cables that go to things that I don't even own it don't you hold onto
them.
What if I do get another Garmin navigation system?
I wouldn't put it in the of rental car.
I each time I had like three or four of these fucking stupid Garmin's all the
new ones different.
Let me get the new one.
This one you download the updates from the internet and you plug it in with the
USB for sure.
Ooh,
it's exciting.
I threw away cables.
I'm like,
what is it male to male USB cable?
Do I need to do it?
No,
you don't need it.
If you need it,
you go to Fry's and you get a new one.
Yeah,
but I had to talk it out like,
like I was on hoarders.
My wife was like,
are we cool to get rid of this?
And I was like,
wait,
let me think about it.
It means something to me that in boxes the box at the shit came in.
I'm like,
just keep those boxes.
It's like for what?
I don't know is the box.
It came in that box.
We should keep that box.
It's part of that from,
you know,
we were all poor.
Like we were all at one point in our life.
We were all poor.
And when you're poor,
you know you,
you,
you like everything is like precious.
You've got to keep the shit.
Is that what it is?
I think it almost goes back to,
I think it goes back to like Christmas,
childhood,
Christmas where it's like the box that the thing came in.
It's like it's as exciting as what's in it.
And it was also super important to returning things.
Like in my house,
my mom returned fucking everything that she bought and they got a new thing.
Like she was always exchanging.
So I feel like I'm almost attached to like,
I might have to,
I might need this for the product later,
even though I never do,
you know,
I've never returned.
Do you ever return things that you buy online?
I've only done it like once or twice out of hundred purchases.
You know,
like,
I don't,
I don't do it a lot.
My wife does it every month.
No,
I could not do that.
Every month she sends something back
again.
I'd be overwhelmed at the idea.
I've watched shit.
I bought shit that's like,
been pretty expensive.
I'm like,
I don't really like this.
And then I just keep it
like an asshole.
Like it just sits there and I'm like,
Eh,
you know,
online shopping is a real fucking problem for some people.
It's become more of a problem that any other kind of shopping,
you realize where it's going to go to.
Like there's going to be that there's no stores at some point.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Well the stores that exist,
uh,
probably like either stores for like large appliances so that you have to
actually go and check out or maybe like,
well,
like small stores that are like owned by people like small.
Have you noticed that?
Like there's these fake like craft restaurants.
They're like fake meaning that like they use like,
like raw metal and like weathered looking wood.
It's not really weathered.
It's not really old.
Whoa.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Like does this like trend,
it's a whole look.
Yeah.
This is like,
what is it called craftsman,
this trend to make everything look like,
yeah.
Isn't it that that was the thing with closed for a long,
I mean it's probably still is right?
Where it's like the jeans that you buy that look like you've had them for years
and um,
yeah.
And then all faded or looks like it's a natural faded look.
But actually they did it in a factory.
Like they made it look faded.
Well,
they beat him up too.
They wreck them and rub them with wire crusher.
We are shipping.
Yeah.
It's very weird.
It's weird that girls can still wear them.
Girls can still wear jeans with like all these fake holes in them.
Dudes can't wear that anymore.
No,
no.
There's the genes for a guy.
There's pretty much what?
There's pretty much three things that are acceptable.
You're either like a skinny Jean Dude Guy,
right?
Like that's just your look.
Or you can be wearing like skin tight baggy jeans or fuck it.
I'm like,
I'm giving up on things.
Sweatpants.
It's like sweat pants or it's like that dad gene,
like where they're kind of like,
like whitewashed almost like they're like light light,
light,
light blue where you're like,
it doesn't look that like good really on anyone.
They kind of where I'm a little too high.
Like the high and tight.
Tight,
tight.
Yeah.
There's,
there's certain looks that are still acceptable for women though.
Like women can go way further with the looks.
You,
they can have holes all over their genes from their pockets all the way down to
like their knees.
How about this?
Speaking of high and tight,
the super high waisted over the naval look where it still looks good.
That's a new thing,
right?
It's like it was old and it came back.
Yeah.
And then over the navel.
Yeah,
over the naval I've seen it.
that's unnecessary.
And you only see it on like really fit women.
Like it's not like,
you know,
like that's like a sexy look.
It's like,
you know,
they do that they can wear,
they can wear a low cut one where it sits below the waist or you can see it like
super low.
That's good.
Yeah.
Well we like it like the smallest amount of cloth between your vagina and an
air.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's what we like.
If you're wearing like some sort of a fucking jumper suit,
it goes all the way up to your neck.
I mean,
I had a quarter,
Roy.
Yeah,
no I don't.
It's too much work.
And then there's like,
it's almost amazing sometimes where like you see,
I'm not even saying it at the beach,
like I'm in a restaurant and hotel ass cheek hanging out of those genes where
you're like,
it kind of stops you in your tracks or something,
right.
Where you're like,
wow,
that's a real ass cheek,
almost naked in this hotel lobby right now.
And then she's just like getting another key for the room.
Thanks a lot.
And you're like,
do you know how you're walking around right now?
You're talking about pants or shorts?
Shorts,
yeah.
Yeah.
You're like,
Jesus Christ,
half of your vagina is hanging out,
hanging out.
And then she was like,
could you not look at me please?
Thanks.
Yeah.
If she's climbing,
if she's stepping a stair
climbing stair and then drops her keys and bends over to pick it up with one leg
up,
you'll see your posting little little lips gonna fall out.
Yeah.
Yep.
Especially if she's got those
horse lips.
My can only hope.
Yeah.
And the frayed them down,
like to get to the crunch is like so small.
It's like barely holds it all together.
We can barely,
yeah.
I mean,
I look,
I'm celebrating that.
Look,
I'm not critical of it,
but it's still is.
It's amazing that that's a choice in society,
right?
Like the barely clothing.
They're working hard and it's,
it's a girl choice.
It's like dudes can't wear daisy dukes.
Yes.
Unless you're trying to get some deck.
Yeah.
I mean you can get that Dick with that for sure.
You can get that deck.
Yeah guys,
you would wear a daisy dukes and like timberlands with like scrunchy socks.
That's a hell of a look.
A certain look where like,
unquestionably,
that dude's want to suck your deck.
Can I got a guy with a construction hat on where a daisy dukes,
no shirt and scrunchy socks with timberlands on that dude's just sucking tech.
That's what he's here for.
And if you see that dude and you make eye contact and you just grabbed your
Dick,
he's going to come over at attack you.
Would that be all?
Yeah.
Fucking manly pasture here man.
Some dude's not into that.
They're into the 20th yeah.
Twinks but you can get in trouble from saint twink.
Did you know that?
Twinks now is that off the table?
The Guy who owns Bravo got in trouble for saying twink he called somebody a
twink the Gig Andy Guy.
Andy Cohen who's out as gay as a guy can be.
Yeah,
he's bought with case a guy,
he's,
he's like,
I would say like perfect gay too.
Like he's got it all going.
Handsome,
handsome,
wealthy.
Yeah.
He'd probably,
great suits.
Just gets Dick and tossed at his phone.
Probably runs out of batteries every five minutes because it's just vibrating.
He gets picks hired at.
Sure.
And how long can a battery,
how many Dick Pics can a battery get before it just dies?
I bet that's kind of pyramid.
Yeah.
Andy knows the answer and that's the name of that segment.
It's called asking.
She just get,
he should be the guy that they test all their iPhone batteries on
or like,
you know,
he's just so successful and he's handsome and go salt and pepper hair.
He's not,
some people don't know this.
He's not just like higher town.
He's the executive.
He makes the programming choices.
Yeah.
It's pretty remarkable.
Hilarious that he has all these housewives like bitching at each other.
Yeah.
Those fucking shows have gotten so brutal.
I watched the real housewives.
My wife watches the Beverly Hills one,
so it was a,
we had it on the Dvr and in the gym in the house.
So I said,
let me watch this fucking shit.
It's like,
it ain't watch the lift house wise.
It doesn't make you angry enough to lift.
It makes you confused me.
You,
you,
you feel so bad for those women.
You want to take them and like take them on a psychedelic retreat or something.
Like what are you doing?
I understand that this is a job and that you're,
you're kind of getting paid to,
to be this person and this,
it becomes intoxicating because you get all this intention and then you got to
kind of get caught up in the momentum of being on the cover of these magazines.
And this girl's got a feud with that girl and I won't work with her and Blah,
blah blah.
But when you watch them scream and yell at each other and Oh my God,
I can't watch that after awhile.
I can't watch the um,
like when they,
cause those shows,
they,
they ride on that.
Like the,
the fuel of that show is confrontations and after you watch,
you know,
so many people argue and insult and get like just meet and shitty.
Like after one commercial break,
after the other,
there's a certain point where I tap out,
I can't do it.
You know what's also for nothing,
right.
You always vote,
but nothing of substance is argument.
Yeah.
It's not like somebody robbed someone in some sort of a business deal.
Tell Cathy that my party was Friday and she said she was bringing them out and I
was like,
you can't fucking bring them out.
It's not your party bitch.
I can't believe it.
Then that's,
that is the episode is that Cathy is bringing Ramon to the fucking party without
asking you just get off those fucking pills.
You had no bad bitch.
These girls were,
one of them was going on.
She said something about,
uh,
you know,
everybody knows about your husband.
You bring my fucking husband up you fucking bed.
She throws a drink at her and throws a glass at her and like,
we don't even know what they know and might not even be real.
I mean they might orchestrate it.
Sure.
I mean they might've said she's going to bring up your husband and you're going
to freak out.
So when she brings up your husband,
there's the fuck out.
Just freak the fuck out.
Throw glass.
And she threw a glass,
but she threw it kind of inner direction like at the ground,
like if you're throwing a glass at somebody,
it's already assault.
Okay.
If you,
if you hit someone in the glass,
the glass breaks.
I think that's assault with a dangerous weapon because it's just,
it means glass.
Are you going fuck someone's face up?
If someone's really trying to hurt you with the glass,
they throw it at you but they're not throwing it at you.
She's like throwing it like sort of at the ground,
like in front of you to make a point.
It's a dramatic and fake.
Took all those bitches and bring them to that projects that you went to.
Oh,
bringing in West Virginia.
Make them hang out with a real housewives,
real housewives.
How it's been.
It's actually mine and mine.
Oh,
you fucking,
what are you talking about?
Hashtags sexy.
Look at how that
one was an ex four books and just opening up her lips and stuff and trouts in
it.
Cal Fish plumping her lips up with just fish guts,
zip beaking a Dick's.
Did you already talk about that guy with the button now?
The biggest dick in the world.
We haven't talked about it.
The Mexican gentleman that has an 18 inch 20 pound dick.
Yeah,
we're,
the circumference of the head is 10 inches.
That Dick Pic,
that would get Andy moist.
It makes not really,
I think nobody wants an ass that's trashed out.
Plus.
That's like a Horse Dick.
That's like the guy who fucking death by the horse.
It's a horse.
It's way bigger than all wars.
Tick.
No,
no,
it's not.
We get on,
well,
the Horse Dick was like literally like an arm.
This is pretty close.
He said it's ruined his life.
He said,
he's like,
I don't know why it affected work,
but he,
you know,
effective jobs.
He said no woman's wants to be with them.
Yeah,
but he's probably,
you're a fucking loser anyway.
Yeah.
Okay.
What do you think he's having fun listening to this episode.
He's like this Mexican.
Yeah.
He can't speak English.
We don't could,
we're not going to stop Mexicans from download your podcast.
They're rapists.
But why don't I say that?
That's bullshit.
Every time I go it was the San Diego.
I'm surprised at how many people come to my show that are from Tijuana.
I really to come up.
Yeah,
you can come up like this is like illusion.
You know,
like people have this idea that you,
it's impossible to like visit the United States from Mexico.
You could totally visit.
Yeah,
sure do.
You can come up all the time.
Like people come up from t one all the time.
Like whenever I do shows down in San Diego,
I do either.
I do the part.
What does that fucking place?
Not the parlor.
What does that shit hole?
Uh,
I dunno.
I only do,
I'm doing the Balboa theatre next time I'm there,
but every time I go,
I always meet people from Tijuana about both.
How big is Baba?
It's pretty big.
2000.
So it's pretty big.
It's a good spot to do the clubs ever gives them to,
sometimes I do American comedy club.
I did that before that small.
I do.
I used to do,
um,
La Jolla Camidge store.
Oh right.
That's really nice.
Right.
It's fucking great.
I used to do that spot,
but then I didn't do the store for like seven years.
But now that I do the store again,
I'm like do that.
I would be into doing it.
I love that place.
You're going to get a call that day about that shit too.
Fond spot,
man.
It's one of the Nick Depalo a recorded one of his cds there and the lawyers.
Yeah,
I think it's first CD recorded down there.
It's a great spot.
It's like the comment you see,
oh,
are in the comedy store,
but it's in La Jolla,
which is a fucking great neighborhood by the way.
It's a nice neighborhood.
That's not the hazard projects.
No.
The lawyer though is tricky if you're raising kids.
Cause I have a friend who grew up in La Jolla and she's like,
it's all just,
everyone's fucked up on drugs.
Like those kids are on Ahcccs in high school.
There's Norton math and they're doing all kinds of crazy shit.
It's like everybody's ignored by their parents.
There's like no real sense of community is rampant materialism.
There's like these,
these a re Oh,
poor baby.
Well,
you grill when up to rich.
I'm not saying that,
but what I am saying is everybody's got their problems.
There's a comfortable medium somewhere,
but the rich people that ignore their kids and they're just constantly focused
on just making money.
That's,
that develop some fucked up kids.
Man.
It reminds me,
everything you're describing reminds me of like the rich kids of Miami.
Oh yeah.
It's like something about the beach,
you know,
sat like the Southern Beach Culture,
uh,
of with lots of money where it was like,
just so like,
kids grew up way too fast.
I think in Miami you can grow up way too fast.
Yeah.
With sex stuff.
With drugs,
it's like,
dude,
what you're having sex,
you're fucking 12 like,
this is so crazy.
Well,
I had to get into concept,
so I had to suck some Dick.
Okay,
okay.
Okay.
Yes sir.
Yeah,
it is dangerous man.
The but those cultures like where you have the rampant materialism in Miami is
one of the biggest show east culture.
So we have and shine.
When you drive down the street,
you're going to see people that have these crazy cars and they have like neon
under the car.
It's like having a Ferrari is not good enough.
You have to have Ferrari with neon underneath it and you have to have big giant
wheels.
There was a fucking,
this guy had a BMW.
I was in Miami recently flew from Costa Rica to Miami and I put a picture of the
car on my Instagram page cause it was so ridiculous.
He had a BMW with like 35 inch wheels,
like wagon wheels on it.
It was so stupid.
It didn't even seem real.
Like I couldn't believe that those were the real wheels he had on his car.
That was in Miami.
Yeah.
The Guy,
the guy who was a driver told us what it was that,
what they call it.
They have like a name for it.
They call it like when you put giant wheels on your car down there.
Super Black,
Puerto Rican.
I Dunno if it's super,
is that super black?
Is that a black move?
I mean I think it's always,
I've always associated it with black stuff.
Sure.
Yeah.
That culture down there,
there's something about that Miami Swag.
Yeah.
There's something about our culture that is also not quite there it is.
Look at the wheels on that.
Come on.
Yeah.
Well get the fuck wheels on that thing.
So stupid.
That's just stupid.
Well this is the size of those things.
I mean that is a four wheel drive.
Like looking we'll let should be on sweet ride.
Man.
That's a nice car.
It's a nice BMW.
Fucked it all up with that.
Yeah.
It looks like they're probably three or four sizes too big.
At least
fucking stupid.
And it's got the like the deep dish that like that doesn't go with that car at
all.
Yeah.
What is it about like having bigger wheels that anybody would ever think would
be good that took off?
I want to say that took off in the,
I feel like in the 90s is everybody,
the whole thing was to get twenties and then I remember the first time I heard
some,
like somebody in a rap song was like,
I'm sitting on 22 cause I was like,
oh shit.
He went up to inches like this dude.
That was a thing.
And then it just must have just taken out where it was.
It's always about trumping that,
right?
Yes.
Yeah.
What do you got and know?
I'm sitting on 30 fives man.
That's so crazy.
Do you remember when they used to have the dub thing by the front front fender
that would show like it would have like the number 26 oh right.
I'm going to show you that.
Show you what I'm riding on the dog.
You know like a boss for 27 those old mustangs,
right.
Would have it on the fender to let you know what was under the hood.
Right,
right.
It would put that next to the front fender wheel,
the wheel size leg.
You know why non Zam dubs
and dubs means twenties right?
Yeah.
That's 20s.
So the magazine Dub is all about twenties,
twenties,
man dubs sac.
It's 20 sack.
Yeah.
That's all about the
coffee culture.
Yeah.
But then Miami culture on top of that has the echoes of the cocaine import
business because when,
when I was in Miami,
I had my buddy Steve Graham did his residency.
Um,
he went to a Ma,
I think it went either went to medical school down there,
but he did his residency down there and,
uh,
he's,
he's an ophthalmologist and he worked in the emergency room and he would show me
these crazy fucking pictures of dudes with like light bulbs stuffed up the Ras.
There's like so many people that come through the emergency room with things and
they're stuck in their ass.
The guy had a gun stuck in his ass.
He had a gun,
a gun stock loaded his ass.
Fuck man,
it's so crazy.
Like a 22 stuffed in his ass hole.
Do you think that that's,
that's uh,
about like showing up someone who's like,
hey man,
you know,
I had a fucking light bulb in my ass.
He's like,
you think you're,
you think you're fucking tough shit.
And then he just grabs a gun and shoved it in his ass.
Bitch,
I'll show you.
I'll show you where I keep my gun pitch,
but you see how raw and you want to know how real I am.
Like Ah,
it spits on his gun.
Just shoves it right down there.
Roland dog edge,
all the,
like the hard edges of them metal,
you know,
it's not a smooth,
like,
like oval shape,
some damage.
God,
I'd be scared of fingernails.
I forgot about it.
Fucking gone.
Remember the guy you saw the,
you saw the one guy,
one cup one John saw Jesus Christ.
That's terrifying.
And it breaks and he's like,
he's dance breaks and cuts him open and then just start shitting out these
chunks of glass.
Like could clink,
clink,
clink.
You don't hear him whimper at all?
No,
he didn't even,
he probably wanted to be hurt.
Yeah.
There's certain people that they believe have a different sensors.
Like they have a different sensitivity to pain.
Like literally they're,
they don't feel pain the way other people feel pain.
And,
uh,
they think that that's like a lot of folks that are extremely into piercing.
They get real nutty with tattoos and piercings and lips.
Eyes.
Yeah.
And then self mutilation,
you know,
like they say that some,
some of those folks like they can't feel they don't like,
and then also it has something to do with some of them.
Obviously not all of them,
but some of them it has something to do with emotional pain.
Yeah,
that makes sense to me.
I didn't have,
I also have heard about like the uh,
that sensory receptors in our brains and some people can get overlapped where
things that are supposed to be like a pleasure receptor goes to pain and pain
goes to pleasure,
you know,
so it's something that that's
supposed to hurt you,
ends up feeling good.
I want the fuck.
Yeah.
Something that's supposed to be like,
uh,
you know that your brain supposed to tell you don't do that.
And something like this is good.
Put a gun in your house,
put a gun and you're all the way in your ass.
It's such a crazy thing to do.
Number that bitten on?
Um,
uh,
it's a jackass when he has the,
the car in his ass,
the little toilet guy.
That's one of my favorites.
And what was that one or two?
I think that's in one.
That's,
no,
I've never watched all,
don't put it up.
I've never watched all of jackass.
Really?
No.
I only watched like a couple stents from like one of them.
I can't,
there's something about those guys doing that shit even though I know they're
alive because they already did it.
Yeah.
There's something about that that I don't like and one of the things that I
don't like is because I've been around dudes like that,
not to the extreme that those guys take it,
cause those guys go too far,
but I'm always like,
you guys are going to get fucked up and then it's not going to be funny anymore.
Right.
Like what you're doing now is adorable.
If you don't get killed or maimed or paralyzed route,
the thing every time,
basically every segment,
someone should be hurt.
Main paralyzed or killed.
Yeah.
Every time.
Yeah,
without question.
Yeah.
It's so crazy what they do.
And the idea that you're getting attention for this is crazy because now other
kids are going to get attention for the same fucking thing and they're going to
try to up you.
Everyone tries to up everybody and he gets to this point where it's,
it's,
you know you're going to hit a wall and you're gonna fucking die.
Yeah.
No,
it's crazy.
I mean,
well the one guy did I not doing it with,
he was drunk driving and driving.
Yeah,
but I think that had to have something to do with the way they were living.
They live crazy.
Dude's push each other.
Right.
And if in you're in that environment where Mikey's,
he's so sick,
he's the sickest.
You think your Schick,
what do you mean Mikey and then Mike,
he's like,
I'm going to do a flip off this building.
Don't like Mikey.
Mikey.
I'm going to put a gun in my ass right now.
Like you're tough shit.
I'm crazy.
I can't watch those.
I can't watch this.
This bit is actually though.
This is the,
it's the funniest and the least like crazy as it and there's,
there's nothing,
you don't see anything being done.
You just see the guy go to the doctor and he goes to a Spanish speaking doctor
and they do an x ray and there's a twit card.
Is that,
and so it's the doctor just talking to them and he's like,
and he's speaking Spanish the whole time and he's like,
ah,
I'm not to party.
Like telling somebody else that this guy was partying and he's like [inaudible]
cooler.
It's hilarious.
He told me it's a little car.
Rico,
is it cut ito?
It's like,
yeah.
Not like Carlito's way.
No,
no.
Got gotta eat those little call.
He,
here's a little card and his ass.
It's a toy car.
Does that,
that doesn't bother me as much as like when Johnny Knoxville after it was a
movie star movie star,
right.
He's doing fucking major motion pictures.
Yes.
Puts
a blindfold on and lets a bull,
it's crazy.
Charge him and flip him through the air.
It's so crazy.
I know you the whole time you're like,
it is crazy that they're alive.
Fuck man,
that bull,
when that bowl launches him and you know,
he doesn't know where the ground is.
I mean,
I guess like you have a sense of gravity but he can't see you.
He's got a blindfold on so he literally has no idea.
And that bull,
just by sheer luck doesn't stomp and madame or shove a horn through his ass hole
or,
or how about when he got,
I think of one of those,
you know,
it's one of these things mean,
it probably better than anybody.
He let's it,
he goes into like a
dude and like just,
let's like just let him unload and like get butter bean is not,
um,
obviously a super fit guy,
but he can throw fucking hammers and he's just punching him in the head.
Everything he's got bouncing off of and he's punching them into walls and shit,
you know.
And it was legal.
They did it because I need butter bean did one with them or he beat one of the
guys up.
I forget which one it was.
He knocked the guy out who was,
I don't know if it was John.
I don't think it was Johnny.
I don't think it was what was Johnny?
Knoxville.
And then there was the one where they had another guy go in with a female Moy
Thai fighter.
She was fucking fuck.
Goddamn too.
I'll take that over.
Butter bean me to butterbeans.
Goddamn terrifying.
That fucking dude hits hard.
Yeah.
He's fat as fuck.
But he's also a giant dude,
you know?
And if you stand right in front of them,
just,
you know how strong you have to be just to carry around all that weight.
Yeah.
Like if Ralphie may lost all that weight,
do you know how strong his legs would be?
Yeah,
he'd be,
cause he,
he's,
every time he stands up,
he's squatting,
whatever that entire,
yeah.
He's carrying 500 pounds and he walks down the street.
He's carrying 500 pounds.
You know,
that's the,
the amount of muscle strength that's required to do that.
I mean,
the pressure on his joints and his knees and crazy ankles and oh,
it's amazing that guys like that can even walk.
Yeah.
You know,
like when you see those,
I was at Disneyland recently and uh,
there,
there's people in the scooters like everywhere,
like everywhere you look,
there's people in these scooters.
They're just overflowing on the sides of the scooters and you're like,
these people have just committed to eating so much.
And they're like,
you know what?
Fuck it.
I just,
I'm just going to motor around everywhere I go,
my joints,
they're just not designed for this.
My back's not designed for this,
but I'm not going to fix anything.
I'm just going to keep eating.
I think they get overwhelmed by how far gone they are.
Yeah.
Because it's too hard to stop.
Too hard to stop.
It's too hard to stop.
And also part of the problem is that all your pleasure now comes from that.
Your pleasure comes from food.
Like I get a lot of pleasure from food.
Yeah,
sure.
You know,
it's,
it's hard to pass up on some yummy food when someone like you pass by a hot dog
stand and you know,
you see the Sauerkraut and you smell the dogs,
he's like,
ah,
I should go for one of those right now.
One of those sweet buns or smushy white bread bonds.
You,
it's all dog
shits all terrible.
You know what you got me into,
I blame you but it's not there anymore.
But I did it with you a couple of times and I was like this.
And then I started to do it without you and pretend I'm you like,
uh,
when we would get back on flights from in the Delta terminal and that place that
used to have that chocolate croissant,
I'm talking about the one,
it's gone like that place shut down.
But we would go there on return flights and get a chocolate croissant and it was
like super rich,
like flaky.
It was buttery.
It was really buttery.
It was like a real good croissant.
Like the,
the,
the pastry part of it is very fluffy and buttery.
Yeah.
And the chocolate was,
you always get the most dog shit croissants on the planet.
Who?
Starbucks.
You said it right when I was saying it.
You knew I knew God.
Their croissants are dogs and they just,
they change.
They were even worse.
They up their game recently.
How recently?
Well I mean what was the last time you had one?
A couple months ago.
Oh really?
And that was the worst.
Horrible.
Oh Wow.
Cause if you had what they had last year it would be even more dramatically dog
shit.
This is Russian bakery that I go to and their croissants are fucking banging a
great buttery rich chocolate one.
This,
this place.
They make their own.
Yeah.
That's the key.
You have Starbucks,
they,
it comes in this little plastic thing and they open it up.
They hire a company that it become corporatized.
Like you don't have to do that.
Like you could make it in house or at least heat them up in house.
Like you have some delivered to you.
This Russian place I go do they sell coffee to and they have chocolate
croissants there.
I'll take you.
If you want to go,
oh,
I want to go.
We'll go after this.
I want to go take you.
It's not that far.
It's so good.
They're the best chocolate croissants I've ever had in my life.
Really?
Oh,
I'm so into it.
I go to a place near my place that,
that they bake them there and they can lay the chocolate and then it's like,
yeah,
it's these Russians.
They take it to another level.
They also put chocolate chips on top of the croissants,
stop it so they feel the inside of the croissant with chocolate chips.
It's melted down when they cook the croissant and then they put chocolate chips
on the top and then it's like a shiny glaze.
You bite into it.
It's like,
Oh,
Christ,
next level.
Next level from the place that was in the Delta terminal,
which was also a next level.
Yeah,
that was great,
man.
That was great.
You know,
and the thing is about,
but eating that rich food too is that now,
like for me,
I love food too.
I always get,
I get so much pleasure from food if I work out the way I've been working out now
where I'm doing like pretty hard workouts.
I feel that thing where it's like your reward.
Oh yeah.
I can eat anything.
You know,
which I can but I do one yourself,
Tom?
Yeah.
Oh he was 16 he's a 26 ounce rib eye right now and it's waiting
butter butter on your buy.
I bought a little butter.
Oh yeah,
the garlic butter.
Yep.
Let it melt in there.
Cut into that flesh and have that butter.
Dip It in the buttocks.
Lobster,
Mac and cheese with truffle oil.
Brand
crumble.
How about different kinds of cheese too?
Oh yeah.
Multiple different cheeses.
Yeah,
a good Mac and cheese,
like a really like tastefully done.
Gourmet Mac and cheese is fucking hard to pass up on where when you pull them
the Mac up the cheese strings,
the melted cheese is like clinging to the fork.
It's like,
oh one of those
TLC did one of those shows where you know like the,
the best Mac and cheese
places in the car.
I almost checked off one like it was so good like it was so I was,
I was so stuck on w I,
I couldn't feel my eyes away from the show.
So good.
It is places that just do Mac and cheese.
I bet they do.
Fox,
I get taste it right now.
What do we die?
What I was gluten free.
Those are the things that I missed was pasta.
I miss linguine with clams.
Like a good linguine with clams is like,
that's how you know if her restaurants for real legit Italian spot.
Right.
They legit Italian restaurant has the linguine with clams.
It's not a soup.
Right,
okay.
Yeah.
It's just like a little,
it's a mild sauce,
a white sauce with the Linguini just,
well you can chew the linguine.
It's got a little bit of a little chew to it.
Yeah.
And then the fucking clams have to be fresh and his little garlic and olive oil
and old.
It was good.
I've been on this foodie kick
on the road lately where I've been going to you just trying to find the best
restaurants in cities and every place seems to have a grilled octopus dish now
and I tear it up every time.
Grilled octopus is very good.
Yeah.
I'm a big fan.
I'm a big fan of it.
Yeah.
I've ordered two and one point I was like,
bring it another way.
I'm sorry.
I'm like,
bring it out again.
That's,
well that's one of the things though.
You're doing really well now.
You started making a lot of money on the road.
You're doing very well and that's when the things you go,
you know what,
I'm going to treat treatment.
Oh yeah,
it's bad.
I don't want to cheat myself.
Upped my workouts and much more.
Yeah,
you were used to working out with Jesus.
I am working out with just working out with them today to see that it,
Tommy has a,
um,
a trainer that will literally tell him how God wants him to work him out.
God wants me to push you to like tell me the time.
Then when he came in,
you were sick,
dude.
It's so bizarre.
So
bizarre.
He's got it.
Dials it back.
Sometimes I'll forget about it and then come up and I'll be like,
what?
Like,
so this time I was,
I,
he's one of those people to,
you know,
the person that makes you feel like you're lying when you're not.
Yes.
Like he's one of those people where like I,
we had a workout scheduled and I could feel like,
like a respiratory thing coming on and I started to feel pretty bad.
So I called them and I go,
hey,
I don't thought,
I don't think we should work out tomorrow because I'm starting to,
I'm starting to come down with something.
So it would be,
we could do it like later in life.
I should take a rest for a couple of days.
Well,
I mean,
like you're sick.
I'm like,
well,
I'm just feeling like I'm getting sick.
Hmm.
Yeah,
I mean,
you know,
maybe just like Kinda gargle some,
uh,
some like sea salt and that's what I do.
And then,
you know,
just get some sleep and then there's,
if you just don't want to do anything,
I'm like,
like,
like I'm not making this up.
You know,
like I,
I,
that sort of tone,
it's a tone of like accusatory.
It's like an accusatory.
Yeah.
It's an accusatory tone of like,
I mean,
are you just a quitter?
He like,
that's what's like behind it and you're like,
dude,
all right.
So the next day I ended up coming and I go,
Hey,
I think,
uh,
you know,
I,
you could hear it,
my voice,
like I,
you know,
is it my chest?
I go,
I think we should just like stick to weights today.
And he's like,
yeah,
cause he like your lungs.
I go,
yeah.
So we keep like my from breathing really hard,
you know,
cause I really doesn't feel good.
I didn't feel well at all.
And he's like,
all right,
so we start off with some weights and then,
I don't know,
like 10 minutes in,
he's like,
bear,
crawl over to there and then bear crawl back and then do some burpees.
And I'm like,
all right,
I just start doing it and you know,
then I'm like,
I'm breathing heavier.
Right.
Cause you're like doing cardio stuff.
I'm starting to breathe heavier.
They didn't make me run downstairs.
It's like hit a heavy bag and then it's like just,
just ups the workout.
And so like 40 minutes into it,
I'm like,
yeah,
so much for like keeping the cardio down today.
Huh.
And he was like,
well,
you know,
I was doing that first and then I kind of started to push you a little bit and
you could do it.
And then I,
you know,
the Holy Spirit,
you kind of like tap me and was like,
you know,
like,
like a little tap on the shoulder like,
you know,
right now,
just pull back a little bit.
So he'll let me know if I,
if I'm ever going to far like it'll,
it'll just give me a,
he'll give me like a warning and I was like,
all right man,
like I don't even know this guy in your act yet.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
When am I,
when can I see you again next?
I haven't seen your act in probably like when's the last time you worked
together?
Six months.
No,
cause we did.
Um,
we did,
we did this house.
We did ice house,
but we did Vegas not too long.
That's right.
But those are weird cause like you're always,
everyone gets distracted like offstage.
Right.
Does I didn't see your set that time.
Yeah.
Well I mean I just,
you know,
that's also a place where you can't see.
That's the coffee at her.
I couldn't get,
just did it.
Right.
I just did it last Friday.
How was it?
It was great.
Crazy drunks crazy.
Oh my God.
It was fun.
It's always fun,
but there's a lot of fucking maniacs and the audience's time this really crazy.
Yeah,
it was pretty crazy.
Um,
yeah that started right away.
Ian Edwards went on stage and like the first thing they do,
they just started,
it was like a few people that were just hecklers.
You're just,
they,
you know what it was too.
It was a light weekend for the fights.
It wasn't that many people there and it was a light weekend for my show and they
gave away some comps and when they give away comps,
that's never good.
It doesn't matter if it's 2000 or a hundred
seat place cops when they say what places?
Yeah,
they w w the gay boy,
a couple of hundred free tickets.
Wow.
That's all you need to do.
Then it goes crazy.
You're going to have a Leech 20 animals.
You give away a hundred free tickets,
you got 10 animals now,
oddly enough,
the um,
the last,
the Mcgregor fight weekend that,
that was awesome.
That was beyond us and we were preparing for,
for massacre.
Like I really,
yeah,
they were great,
but also like it fed itself.
The nervousness was like we talked about,
I think it was just a real brief,
like could be real crazy tonight and that's all I needed to hear.
And like I was just imagining 2000 Irish drugs,
like fuck,
like just screaming at me.
And so I was really like prepared for like,
oh,
this can be bad.
You know,
I went into it like that,
which maybe is why it was,
I felt so good because it was the opposite of that.
Well that was a great crowd though.
They were really,
they were a remarkable,
we're so good.
I mean it just like you would never have imagined there was 2000 people in that
room in 2000 plus or whatever the fuck it seats.
It will,
it seemed like it was intimate.
Like they were,
they were great.
Oh they were just excited about that weekend.
Do you know what the Jesus trainer also did recently was a,
we were doing,
well there's a,
there's a type of rack where you can squat,
but it also has arms that go out this way so you can,
it basically puts it at hip level and do like power cleans and stuff off of it.
So it's on there.
The bars on there and he's having me change out,
go up by tens so it's like 10 on each side and then 20 and 30 and 40 50 and I
was like,
should I use the bigger weights?
Cause we're just adding tens.
And he's like,
no.
Okay.
And then he's like,
you know what,
take them all off and now start putting on bigger ways.
I'm like,
all right,
so I have six tens like on each side.
So I take those all off and I put 45 and then 25.
Then he's like,
and then after a while he's like,
how's that good,
we keep going up.
And he's like,
yeah,
I go,
what?
And he's like,
Holy Spirit was,
uh,
told me that like
to have you use the bigger weights for your risks.
I know sometimes you have problem with your risks.
So I think by you moving around those heavier weights,
it's better for your wrist.
But it was the holy spirit that told him to have me stop doing the lighter
weights and use the bigger way you risk get sore sometimes.
Like sometimes,
you know,
um,
my wrist,
I think,
I feel like I have like just weak wrists,
like in general.
So I have sometimes I have some pain there.
Or,
um,
like with w with power cleans,
you know,
instead of like having them underneath,
like I have like maybe a limited range with them,
but as far as like how far it goes back.
Yeah.
So it,
it hurts sometimes and I'll have like suggested maybe I should get,
you know,
those traps [inaudible] traps or something.
What we should,
we just had conversations about it,
but you know,
um,
what,
what can help as well is,
um,
there's
some mobility exercises to stretch out your risks.
That could help a lot for most people.
If you,
if you live your life up to a certain point and you've never really,
uh,
pushed him,
they have a limited range of motion,
which is based on it,
but you can,
you could change that range of motion with stretching.
Um,
but another thing that can help the strength of them is,
uh,
do you ever have a roller?
Do you know what that is?
Like you have a,
a,
a stick and there's a long string on the bottom of it and then you put a weight
at the bottom of the string and then you roll it up.
I've seen those.
Yeah.
It's a great for strengthening the wrist and strengthening the forearm as well.
Those are really good for that.
If you ever read that forearm strength is hereditary isn't,
that's what I've read.
I don't know if it's,
if it's true or not.
I mean,
obviously you can work on it,
but,
but you know,
some people just have that like natural,
incredible strength,
like forearm strength,
like with a grip.
Yeah.
Well it's also the size of the hands.
You know,
that that has a big factor because if you have small hands,
very difficult to have.
Strong forearms are strong hands.
If they're small,
they're small.
Well,
it's like there's leverage in having a larger hand,
like guys have like this big Kareem Abdul Jabbar,
like Shaquille O'Neal must have like a grip of death.
Like I,
she shaked Shaquille O'Neal's hand,
my hand disappears in his hand and it becomes like a little child saying,
yeah,
yeah.
I noticed even in like his stature is not as big.
You know,
he's only like five,
nine or 10 but that with,
with Tyson.
Oh yeah.
His,
his,
his hand went around my hand.
Well he's got a fucking hammer.
Fists,
you know.
And when you have a thicker,
like longer fingers,
it's like in Jujitsu,
one of the things that a is a big advantage is having a longer limbs.
Like guys who are long like this,
this Guy Heidrick Gracie,
he's long and tall and he finishes a lot of guys with arm armbars and triangles
and he has all this extra leverage because he has length and for chokes,
guys with long arms are really good a lot of times and getting chokes off their
back like triangle chokes and chokes from because they have more length of their
bone.
They have like a longer,
there's a long,
there's more leverage and get around.
So it makes sense with hands too.
Like someone would like longer hands.
It's more,
they can crush you more.
There's more there.
But like little hands,
like you're fucked.
Like,
like people with little hands,
very difficult for them to generate power.
You can be fast and there's a certain amount of power involved in speed.
But like a George Foreman,
one of the things that people like apparently George Foreman,
I never shook his hand,
but it's like shaking it canned ham.
Oh.
Cause I was just fucking monstrous again.
Club have a hand.
Well he was just,
that was just a fucking sledgehammer that would come on.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
That's one of the reasons why,
but the human body like vary so much.
I mean there's so many different things that are definitely genetically like it
there advan advantageous.
It's one of the weird things about the argument when it comes to steroids are no
steroids or a performance enhancing drugs.
Yeah.
Like there are advantages to being born with certain genetics for giant
advantages.
I have small ions.
They're not tiny.
They're not tiny,
but they're pretty small.
It's pretty average.
I think it's might be like we might fit the actual measurements of the National
American Societies for Sig meetings now for average Dick for average.
Yeah.
Not like that Mexican dude.
How big you think his hands are?
How,
how if you could,
if you,
if you had his dick,
it wouldn't be good.
Right.
But his hands are like those big phone number ones.
Would you want a Dick like that?
No,
but if you can shape the perfect Dick,
listen,
what measurements would,
my Dick could have been a disaster.
Everybody's Dick could have been designed and we've all met people with birth
defects,
all sorts of,
I'm very happy with my deck,
but if you could shape wicked,
I won't even enter this conversation when enter the conversation.
Great.
Yeah.
I'm a fan.
I like mine.
I like the worst man.
Yeah.
Of Micro Dick's and there's not a goddamn thing in the world they can do about
that.
And that's,
and that is really fucking sad.
It's so sad and it's real and there's,
there's nothing they do.
There's nothing they can do.
We've all seen,
like I went to see this guy once in a concert.
He took his pants off and he's called,
he calls himself extreme Elvis and part of his gag was that he has the tiny
stick you've ever seen.
I mean,
his Dick is like,
and I'm not bullshitting his dick is like the bottom two digits on my pinky.
Really?
Yeah.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's so small and this guy would take off his clothes and he would,
he was owning it.
Right.
He was trying to just own it up.
Yeah.
That was his,
that sucks.
Yeah.
He's fucking talented as shit to really like really good singer,
great band.
And uh,
it was a crazy show.
He would,
um,
he would take off his clothes and he would piss on the audience.
He would pee on people.
Um,
he would,
uh,
pice is GG Allen now.
He had this girl that he was,
uh,
his,
his was,
she was a singer and she would take her top off Chad,
great tits to,
she's pretty,
and she was talented.
She was like a talented musician and he would pee in her mouth.
He's like,
oh.
He was like,
who wants to drink for King's pissed?
She's like,
I do.
Any pissing her mouth.
What?
What's his name?
Extreme Elvis.
Jesus man.
Because GC you've seen tangible stuff,
right?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He would smear shit on people.
He had a little Dick.
Yeah.
And he didn't happen.
Parade.
That should around.
Yeah.
Maybe that's where all the rage came from.
I bet it has something to do with it.
Yeah,
for sure.
It has something to do with it.
A lot of people's rage comes from being fucked with and from.
Also feeling the inequality.
You know,
you feel like you got fucked.
Like you've got a shitty hand.
Goddamn.
And look at these fucking two ones.
This motherfucker's got a full house.
Yeah,
that's true.
I think my best hands fucking bullshit.
God dammit.
That's life micro Dick,
my crowd deck.
And there's not as a whole damn thing they could do about it for now.
But the day they fix it,
oh we're going to have a lot of those Mexican dudes around.
Oh dear.
She had been,
I did used to do about big Dick Pills.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I've seen it.
yeah,
yeah.
Little my best bits.
Yeah.
That was great.
Big Dick Pills.
Yeah,
but that,
that is more doing big Dick Surgery at Wichita.
But I saw a thing one time,
a video on it where like that shit looked.
So what happened on the video?
I saw the guy got like the,
the injections and everything.
It just looked um,
like a,
like a rubber sleeve,
but there were no veins in anymore,
you know,
it was just like,
and I don't think it got hard,
it just was,
it was big and doughy and,
and like,
like half full.
It was like a bigger limp dick,
but it looked fucking weird.
So he would just like smack people to,
yeah,
check out this big soft click.
Fuck you.
You Ain't
God.
Yeah.
18 inches though.
They can't do a damn thing about a micro Dick,
which is amazing.
They figured out a way to make it hard.
That's one thing they figured out pour that changed the world.
The guy who figured out Cialis and Viagra,
that guy must have made so much.
Oh my goodness,
I'm out of money.
They must be doing that stuff.
Oh my God.
It's vasodilators,
right?
They figured out a way to,
and you know those are banned from the Olympics.
Did you know that?
Really?
See what they open your capillary.
Well,
they help performance.
They help your endurance.
You get more blood.
Yeah.
Just totally makes sense.
But I think that if you could figure out a way to actually make something,
we're dude's Dick [inaudible] grew,
it would probably be the most,
the most lucrative investment ever.
Yeah.
There was there,
because everybody,
even if like you're thrilled with your dead,
someone was like,
yeah,
that's fun.
Just try one.
You're going to,
you're going to buy it out an inch.
Yeah.
You wouldn't want another extra inch.
An inch.
Yeah.
Come on.
Just you.
You're like,
I'll take it.
You're happy with it,
right?
You thrilled.
Yeah.
Are you thrilled?
And they start getting like agents as the salesman,
like,
you know,
they're all sales.
So I was like,
get fucking all the agents in there and being like,
speaking of lucrative.
I was with,
with Ian Edwards this weekend and know Greg Fitzsimmons and Ian and I were a
flying home and we were at the terminal and we ran into this girl that,
uh,
Ian knew,
from the store and apparently she's a stripper.
And,
uh,
she,
we were sitting down having a coffee and she asked if she could sit with us.
I said,
yeah,
sure,
go ahead.
Sit with us.
And so she started talking about working at spearmint,
rhino,
stripping and this and that.
And she worked this weekend and she was coming back and you know,
she was just talking about,
you know,
everybody was cheap and this and that,
that and this.
And then she said she was working with this girl.
She's working with this girl and the girl.
Uh,
I go,
what percentage of the girls that you work with are willing to have sex with
guys for money?
And she's like,
um,
there's quite a few.
She goes,
I worked with this one girl this weekend who was like,
how lucrative do you get?
And she goes,
what?
She goes,
how lucrative too you get.
Cause I get,
I be getting lucrative.
And and she goes,
what do you mean lucrative?
Says I'll go,
I'll go back to a dude's hotel room for $1,000.
I'll get lucrative,
lucrative,
lucrative.
And this girl was married to a guy apparently that is not gay but is a dancer.
She dances for men and he does,
he's gay for pay.
Yeah,
he's gay.
It's a,
her husband is her husband.
He's like five guys were on a train off.
It's so fucking unacceptable,
dude.
Hey,
one night he doesn't have to work for the rest of the month.
Okay,
how's that?
How,
how's your sleep?
Are you sleeping well?
Is Everything good
you out of your fucking mind?
He's lucrative.
I saw that like a MTV.
Oh,
MTD real thing.
They did that when the guy where he was like,
I'm not gay and these six guys,
we're about to blow these six guys.
I saw that and they were all clowning him.
Do you remember that?
They were all openly gay and they were like,
dude,
you're sucking our Dick Today.
And he's like,
I'm getting fucking getting super lucrative.
He had a girlfriend too,
and his girlfriend was like,
I don't like it,
but it's really his job.
And his Crawford was like kind of homely and he's a good looking guy.
Yeah.
And I remember the line that he had to say in the video,
anal sex is the bomb.
That's what he had to say before the Jews ran a train on him.
Fuck man.
He's just getting lucrative.
Get,
get,
get.
I get pretty lucrative.
Ho
how,
how crazy this shit get in a Vegas Strip club on fight weekend.
This girl,
man,
I was just a wished we had more time.
Yeah,
she could tell me more crazy stories.
More lucrative stories.
How lucrative do you get?
What's that?
Um,
stripper stripper fees like with strippers said or something you don't talking
about.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
God Damn it.
Pretty funny.
I met,
that was one of the guys that is,
it works for that feed has a buddy that fights in the UFC and so I go back and
forth.
I do it sometimes on a,
on Twitter because I follow them.
Yeah.
Stripper genius.
Yes.
It's a little bit,
some of this shit is hilarious on their feed.
I can't wait to be completely done dancing because I'm sick of digging my
fucking t bar out of my ass crack all night.
That's kind of mild.
Yeah,
it's mild,
but there's some good ones in there.
There's some good ones in here.
Stripper genius fall that on the Twitter I'm with my new guy said no more
masturbating for me.
Okay,
here it is.
Maybe if you ate a burger,
you'd have some ass and titties.
I've done cocaine with a lot of rock stars.
Too many.
Really?
I'm sorry if my breath smells like tomatoes and liquor.
I like that.
Uh,
uh,
there are two.
There's too many bitches and not enough sluts.
Amen.
Sister
fucking booty calling a hoe just to get bitched out is depressing and I'm using
all right.
It's like a Dick for some pizza right now.
These are all good.
They're not bad.
There's good ones in there,
but you got to fish for them.
They should post a less quality over quantity because some of those are just not
that interesting.
Yeah,
but some of them are,
but the good thing is they're all real like they're not like,
there's not like a comedy writer who's like trying to find out what the funniest
shit that a stripper could say.
So they should use that on stripper genius though.
How lucrative for you will it again please.
How lucrative the you get.
I get put in lucrative man.
You imagine a girl like a Rosie Perez accent.
Yeah.
That's,
that's the perfect person to say it.
I go real liquidity.
How lucrative are you willing to get getting back in the day?
Yeah.
Put that phone down Tommy addicted.
You're just searching for more,
right?
Yes.
Super Addictive.
You should.
Fear has a really good fucking point.
I'm not following them into the abyss.
Of of the flip phone but he's like in,
in the morning,
in the morning.
I would wear this to half an hour every morning or just get off.
But your first book or dropped my Twitter.
He's right.
I do it.
I take my morning shit.
I get excited to bring that phone into the bathroom and do the exact same thing.
That shit.
I'll walk towards the bathroom be like oh I forgot that shit turn around.
Cause there's some people's Twitter feeds that are fun.
I want to follow him.
I don't want to fun.
And there's always like some new news story or some interesting things going on.
Most of my news from a Twitter feed,
you know in the bathroom.
Yeah.
Cause I got,
I'll follow breaking news New York Times,
like what's going on right now?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Rip West Craven.
Fuck.
That's how I found out.
What's the trending stuff for sure.
That's how I found Robin Williams died last winter and Robin Williams.
I was like what?
Yeah,
no way.
That one didn't feel real.
Yeah,
I remember I saw that written down or IP.
Robin Williams was like,
what?
Crazy that one year just passed on that I couldn't believe it.
Yeah,
it flew,
right?
Yeah,
it did.
That's one thing that you'll find,
especially once your kid is born time accelerate every year quicker every year.
Like your kids were babies.
Like I feel like yesterday.
I do.
Yeah,
and your kids w it's going to be the same thing with you and then one day
they're going to be off to college.
Sorry off.
You know,
being an adult,
how old now?
How old are you arriving in?
Five.
Yeah.
It's weird.
It's,
it's real weird watching other people's kids grow up too.
And also,
here's another thing that's weird.
Watching people's bad parenthood skills manifest themselves and their kids.
You see it.
I have a friend who's got a fucking eight year old is still sucks his thumb and
he thinks it's okay.
He's like,
it's some big deal.
I go,
no,
it's a big deal.
Like your kids sucking his thumb.
Yeah.
Like this is not like healthy behavior.
You're not supposed to be sucking your thumb when you're eight,
you're kid's going to get fucked with.
He's getting get fucked with by other kids in school if he's not already getting
fucked with like that's just weird.
You start,
um,
I started paying attention more.
You know,
you started to key into things more like we're at a restaurant and now when we
see like you're sitting next to a table where it's a family and they have the
kid and the kid's like seven,
eight and he's on an iPad with the volume up either watching a video or playing
a game and you're hearing people beautiful and you're sitting here like they are
teaching him that.
That's okay.
Like be entitled,
be oblivious and like,
how are you not telling them we're in a restaurant right now,
you know,
at least if you're going to check out and play games,
bring them.
No one wants to hear the explosions.
But I start to pick up on that more like there that that's why that when that
guy grows up and he's oblivious to like,
Whoa,
what's everyone's problem that I'm doing fucking whatever I want.
No matter who's around me all the time.
Cause they put it in them,
they let them know it's okay.
No one told them like,
no,
you have to be considerate of the people around you.
Well,
electronics are so unnatural to,
uh,
we all love them.
You know,
everybody loves a good movie or everybody loves to look at their phone or check
their email.
It's for whatever reason,
it's compelling.
But there is so unnatural that when you're all sitting around a dinner table and
there's five people and everyone's like staring at an Ipad,
see it all the time now.
Yeah.
At least a phone.
You know,
but for little kids,
what it is,
is there,
kids are hard to tune into that.
They,
they,
they care about shit.
You don't give a fuck about like a,
I took my kids out for breakfast this morning and,
uh,
we're sitting around and we're,
we're coloring.
You know,
a lot of times when you,
uh,
go to a restaurant,
they have a kids menu and they give you some crayons.
So we're drawing,
you know,
and they want to,
but she's like,
can I play with your phone?
Like,
no,
let's just do this.
Let's just do this.
Let's do this.
But that fucking phone is better.
What age do you give him a phone?
I don't know.
That's a good question.
I think that age changes when a right,
yeah.
That you can,
there's a new thing that they have for kids.
It's like a wristband.
The ILEC all,
almost like a watch type thing that has a tracking device on it.
Tell you what your kids are all the time and there's a button they press on.
It will,
it will call you only you sound a phone,
but it call you like dad.
He left me over by pirates of the Caribbean and lost and then you got to go find
your kid.
Do they have that?
Yeah.
Wow.
They have that.
That's cool.
And then like that's step one when your kids are going to be calling you all the
time.
Yeah.
Pressing that button.
Dad.
I Hate Second Grade Bullshit,
dad.
I don't want to go to school.
Dad,
you're gonna get that a lot or not.
Maybe they love it.
That's true.
Yeah.
They could.
The idea that a kid is supposed to be thinking about what they want to do for
their future,
those crazy,
like there's people that are prepping their kid
for whatever.
I remember that future I remember cause I went to school with that were being
prepped for med school in,
in elementary school.
So I think it's kind of fucked up for you and I more than anybody else,
especially because we actually love what we do and what we do is so discouraged.
Yeah,
true.
But nobody says,
Tommy,
you should really be a standup comedian.
No,
just start fucking with your teachers.
Now
is there any kid in class,
it really stands out as being annoying.
Can you imitate him?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Start imitating them and put them in ridiculous scenarios like in Napoleon's
army.
And I'll
start doing an impression.
If you think of something funny to say in a really serious moment in class,
just blurt that shit out.
Yeah.
If you can get a laugh in class.
That was the Sharon math class.
Oh,
that was the greatest thing that we had a thing.
And when I was in fifth grade where like if you got in trouble in the first part
of the day,
you didn't go get to go to recess,
you know?
And then recess is like everything.
Recess is like,
Hey,
do you want to go to Fiji to adult,
you're a kid.
And they're just like,
recess is a fucking shit.
And I remember like biting my lower lip and be like,
Oh,
if I say this,
I'm my God,
we get taken out of recess.
But then I'd be like,
ah,
just say it anyways.
And then it's like,
no recess,
you know?
But like it was worth it to,
to make everybody in stupid class laugh.
I wasn't funny in school,
like with things I said,
but I would draw things that were funny.
I would draw cartoons like we had this guy,
Mr. White,
Mr. White was crazy.
He went to Vietnam and bad things happened to him over there.
Really?
Apparently.
Yeah,
he was shell shocked.
That's what we used to call it back then before they,
he's called PTSD,
but a,
he was a real tiny guy.
He was like five too.
So every time I would draw I would draw him standing out box or standing on a
chair or standing on a stool and he would,
uh,
like someone asked for a pencil once and uh,
he goes,
you want to pencil?
He goes,
come here,
come over here.
And he takes the drawer from his desk.
He Yanks it out,
it's got pencils in it and slams it on the ground and he goes,
take one of those pencils.
Holy Shit.
And everybody was like,
what the fuck?
And we all knew that this guy had been to Vietnam.
Like he would talk about it occasionally,
you know,
that's pretty terrifying to do the,
he was,
you know,
in a good school system to,
well this was Newton south high school.
Okay.
So Newton south high school,
it's like they did bus kids in from bad neighborhoods and that,
that was an issue because they did bring these kids in from like Dorchester and
Matt,
a Pan,
like really bad neighborhoods.
And there was definitely a difference,
which are,
and everybody's like,
oh,
like these lambs of,
of these,
uh,
suburban lambs and then these,
urban wolves that would come into the city,
but it wasn't too bad,
you know,
it wasn't like gangs or anything crazy.
And this was like,
I went to high school,
I graduated in 85 and that was before like rap music is before,
like straight out of Compton and all that crazy shit.
Where were things like escalated,
right?
Like violence and like rap music,
no matter what anybody says,
absolutely perpetrated like a different sort of acceptable mentality or a up,
a different sort of behavior they aspire towards.
That wasn't going on when I was in high school.
So when I was in high school,
like Sugar Hill gang was like the big thing,
right?
There was like junior high school,
I said the hip hop hip to the hippity hip hop.
It was,
it wasn't that kind of the kind of music that was,
you know,
it just wasn't gangster rap,
gangster rap score,
chase bank,
Hank,
um,
forgot what my point was.
Uh,
they were just,
they weren't that bad in this guy.
So this guy,
Mr. White was growing up in this neighborhood and in this neighborhood it really
was,
you know,
wasn't,
it wasn't like a dangerous play.
Sure.
But he would fucking freak out and was a good dude though.
He was a really nice guy and he's a very smart guy too.
Like I had some really interesting conversations with a moves,
very aware,
but he just had a trigger that will,
he took a joke really well.
They'll tell you that man,
I never got upset at my cartoons.
Really?
He laughed.
Thought they were funny,
man.
Dude.
But it's funny when you grow up to think of your teachers as people as opposed
to like when you're a student and a kid,
teachers are like,
you know,
you don't imagine your parents are people,
they're your parents.
And teachers have like that special place that like,
that's Mr. White.
Yeah.
And you say they're like their names,
like,
I dunno,
like it just,
and you grow up and you're like,
oh,
that was a miserable fucking guy.
Like he,
like,
I remember teachers that were just hate,
like clearly hated teaching,
you know?
Yeah.
There was a lot of those man.
Yeah,
there was a lot of,
you know,
there's no money in it.
There's no money in it.
You imagine just dealing with a new crop of asshole teenagers every year that
don't give a fuck about you.
But I,
you know,
one of the things that really bummed me out man was people that would say like
negative shit to kids and not realize the impact that negative shit has on that.
I got,
I,
uh,
I've told this before,
I think when I was in,
this was the only laugh I think I ever got in high school in the,
in the class,
but I got kicked out for it.
My teacher,
she was black and she got a terrible accent and she's taking teaching math and,
uh,
I was not paying attention and,
probably talking and she was missing or broken.
Would you like to come up here and do both of these questions for this class?
And a,
I said,
would you like me to do both of those questions?
And the fucking pool.
It was just like,
there was like a pause like no he did.
And then
like everybody started and then she goes and she goes,
you know,
get,
she kicks me out and she goes,
don't laugh.
Go ahead.
You know Mister Brogan is going nowhere in life.
I'll tell you this right now.
And then she kicked me out of the class.
I remember thinking that like what a rude thing to say to a 14 year old who by
the way you may be teaching math,
but yeah,
you might want to learn work on English because that's not how you say both.
You don't say both.
There's not an f in there.
So when you save itself and I,
all I did was say,
would you like me to do both of those questions?
I said it the way you talk and I got in trouble for that.
Well that seems pretty fucking ridiculous.
If your accent is so bad that all I have to do is imitate it and it gets a giant
laugh in the class.
You know what I did and I know what I did and the whole class knows what I did.
I corrected your shitty way of talking and that got me kicked out and not just
kicked out like I'm going to say it's a fight.
I remember in work,
but it could have,
yeah
they were.
We could,
I know I witnessed a teacher tell a kid you're nothing and you're not going to
amount to anything.
And it was in a moment of rage.
Like I could see that the kid had just gotten in big trouble.
So it was like he was flipping out.
What did the kid get in big trouble for?
He,
we were on a um,
uh,
like a school trip and he had fucked around with the air conditioning at a
public place.
Like,
and he,
he said it,
he said he set it at 90.
So he said he'd gone but he was kind of a truck.
He was a troubled kid.
Right.
And this teacher said that to him.
Man,
I remember all of us that were in the room cause we weren't all,
it was only like 10 of us when this guy came in to like to yell at him.
We were all just stared at the ground cause it was,
he was,
he was so full of rage when he said it to this kid.
But he really went,
I mean,
he went in hard.
I'm not even doing a fraction of that.
He was like,
you're not shit and you're not going to amount to shit.
Ooh,
what the fuck?
Yeah.
He's treating that killer grown up.
How old were they?
The the,
the kids.
Yeah,
we were,
uh,
I think juniors in high school.
So we were old enough.
Yeah.
But like,
it's still is fucked up to say picked up.
Yeah.
Fucked up,
man.
Ooh,
that's 16.
Yeah.
16 to seven.
Well,
you know what man,
some of those guys who just,
it's,
there's PTSD and being a teacher too,
man for stress and pressure that you have to deal with and that's fine.
Trying to raise your family and everything on that bullshit salary,
that bullshit salary.
Yeah.
That's why when you get a good one,
it's so memorable.
I had a really,
really good English teacher,
a really good English teacher and really good Spanish teacher.
The English teacher was so nice.
She was so nice and everybody loved her and they got psyched when they got her.
Yeah,
because she was like,
she would talk like she was an older lady when I was in high school.
I got to imagine she was probably in her late fifties,
early sixties and uh,
she would talk about sex and she would talk about like romance and a,
you know,
like how,
she was like talking about like literary works and then she would talk about how
it applies and like what you're going to experience in your own life.
And it's going to be times in your own life where you just think that this is
everything and this person's everything to you and they'll engine,
those are wonderful moments.
She goes put,
they're transient and sometimes they go way,
especially when you're young,
you're young and you're having sex with each other and people and people are
like,
what the fuck is she saying?
Yeah,
we couldn't believe that you seem you're having sex.
And she's like,
and then you know that person might have sex with somebody else and you're just
going to be devastated,
but maybe they're just going to love you more.
Once they do that,
you know,
maybe they'll make that mistake and then they'll will just make them appreciate
and accept you more.
But some people can't.
They can't deal with that.
And I remember her saying that,
I was like,
Whoa,
this is deep shit.
That's pretty deep.
High School English class as old ladies talking about fucking people and
cheating,
jealousy and everything and how silly it all was and how in perspective when she
was trying to,
you know,
give us like some,
I forget what the work that she was referring to,
like what,
what book we're talking or would a stories we were discussing that made her,
I bring that up.
But I remember thinking like,
wow,
this lady just dropped some experience knowledge.
Well,
I out,
I'll never forget her saying that like that,
you know,
when someone leaves you or someone cheats on you,
it'll feel like the most devastating thing ever.
But they might really just feel better because of like,
they might love you more because of that.
It might be better for your relationship after that's over.
She went through some shit,
man.
She must have.
She must have,
but it was the way she was describing it to the class.
I had a great sign.
I had a great Spanish teacher to Spanish teacher was awesome.
He's like,
yeah,
he was like friendly and fun.
But then after I graduated I found out that he was banging students.
Whoa.
Yeah.
That's,
he was so friendly.
Yeah.
He Bang one of my friends.
Wow.
When she was 17.
Yeah.
She started,
he started banging her like as she was a senior in high school.
I like,
I think he banged her a little bit as she was graduating two balls.
It was the American.
Yup.
Yeah.
How old was he?
He was a handsome guy.
Um hmm.
I wish I knew.
I would have to say I shit.
You know,
obviously I was 17 so he was an adult.
I would say he's in his twenties maybe.
Oh,
okay.
So that's relatively a young teacher though.
Yeah,
I'd probably like twice.
I mean,
graduated from college so he has to be like 20 phase,
not 54 no,
it's probably 30 like 29 30 somewhere in that range.
But I was surprised he was banging and 17 year olds and I was like,
oh hey buddy.
I mean,
look in perspective,
if he's 43 and the girls 30 it's nothing but,
but yeah.
And your students are different than yes.
Yes,
he did.
He last long there.
Do you know if he's,
I don't remember.
I don't know.
I don't,
you know,
I,
once I was gone,
I was gone,
man.
When I was,
when I graduated from high school,
I fucking graduated.
I mean,
I never even went back and got my diploma.
I didn't go to my graduation.
I didn't even want it.
I was like,
I don't want to have anything to do with this place.
I just wanted to be free,
get out of there.
I wanted to be,
I just,
I just knew whatever they were selling,
whatever they were pushing,
whatever,
what,
whatever mold they were trying to get me to fit in.
It was unacceptable and I had to figure out what I had to like detox from
whatever they did to me.
And it wasn't their fault.
It's like they're just teaching.
It's what every what,
every kid experiences when they're,
when they're being forced into doing something they don't want to do.
Along with the pressure of growing up,
along with the pressure,
uh,
you know,
whatever your parents are putting on you with expectations your or your family
might have.
And with me,
there's a lot of expectations are the key.
The people that I knew,
like a lot of the kids that I was going to school with,
they were all set up for college and they all have these ideas of what they were
going to do.
And I was lost.
I was like,
I didn't know what I wanted to do.
I was competing in martial arts tournaments,
but I knew there was a limited amount of future with that.
I was like,
where can I take this?
And I knew that eventually if I kept going to,
I was kind of get brain damage,
how's it?
I'm probably already getting a little bit of it and I was like this,
if I keep going,
I'm going to wind up fucked in the head and I go,
I'm going to wind up slurring my words or something.
Fuck yeah,
for sure.
Especially once I started kickboxing.
So,
but I also knew that a job,
like a job job,
like an office job,
fucking unacceptable man.
I can't do it.
I just won't.
I don't,
I have too much energy or I have too much impatience or something.
I mean,
I'm not gonna be able to sit down.
So I just had a wait until I got out of there to try to take a deep breath.
I took a year off,
didn't do anything for a year,
just worked,
worked and competed.
And,
um,
then I started going to a Boston or a Umass Boston for a,
just like they had like a continuing education program.
Like he didn't have to take your sats.
Yeah,
I never took my sats.
Yeah.
So I just went and I did that for three years and then I was like,
what am,
I'm just wasting my time.
Yeah.
Fucking complete waste.
I fucking,
I knew that in an office it would be,
I think my literal death,
I could feel the depression of it sitting in,
you know,
like all it especially cause it was,
I think it's a lot of it,
it's not that working in an office is the worst.
It's that it wasn't meaningful work.
It wasn't anything that I cared about and any of the office jobs I had were just
something to do.
Cause you're supposed to have a job then what did you think you wanted to do
when you were in high school?
Like when you're like,
you're 17,
you're about to graduate,
what do you want to do?
I knew I wanted to do comedy,
but ideally,
yeah.
But I didn't know I wanted to do standup.
I really thought that I think is because what's accessible or what seemed
accessible or like the thing that I responded to was watching movies,
you know,
and t so I thought I would be,
uh,
a comedic actor of some kind,
you know,
like I,
that's what I thought.
Who was your favorite?
Um,
I love,
I mean I loved like the,
you know,
Belushi,
no Ackroyd I liked him.
I liked Bill Murray a lot and I liked the Eddie Murphy.
Like those were kind of like,
like my two favorites as a course,
you know,
so like I thought everything,
both of their schools are like,
their,
their styles are really different.
But to me they were like
the really the fun Chevy Chase and stuff.
Like those guys were like the funniest fucking guys to me.
Whatever happened to Bob and Doug,
Mackenzie,
Bob and Doug Mckenzie member,
the honey,
I shrunk the kids guy.
Oh yeah,
with the glasses.
Yeah.
And then there was the other,
they had a show.
Isn't that Rick Maranas?
Yes.
He said he quit acting.
What happened with that guy?
He quit acting because he just didn't want to be,
that's what I read.
He didn't want to be in uh,
in the,
and they thought the business was ridiculous.
He,
a lot of people that feel like that is you start at certain point,
we just don't want to have anything to do.
I think he like,
he moved to like,
uh,
you know,
just off,
not off the grid really,
but like just away from La and just done,
done.
Just know he does for a living.
I did too.
I wonder,
I forget,
I read an article about him,
about how he just starting and movies and it was just like,
fuck this over it.
It's interesting that some,
some people do,
they have that wake up moment or like,
okay,
well this is not what I wanted to do.
It's not what I thought it was and now that I'm doing it,
I got to get out of this.
Yeah.
I mean if you're working in entertainment too,
especially like on the,
the acting,
you know,
directing side of things.
Like,
if you're like one of the,
I could see how there's so much nonsense involved in the business side of that,
that it's very,
at some point I could,
you know,
you can be very talented and not be working at it and be like,
what am I doing?
Just trying to get into the system,
you know?
Yeah.
Well it seems unattainable.
And when things seem unattainable,
you think you want them,
right,
right.
Yeah.
You think you do.
Well,
that's what I think happens to a lot of people when they get that reality show
fame.
You know,
they think they look at it,
they're like,
if I was famous boy,
everything could be great.
And then,
you know,
you wind up being one of the housewives.
It's like on the cover of the magazines and then you realize how many fucking
people hate you.
Yeah.
The anger.
Or have you ever like seen like the TMZ comments one of those like real
housewives gets in trouble like Jesus Christ,
you're hated.
Yeah.
Monsters out there that are focusing their rage for whatever disappointment they
have in their life on you because you're the chick on the housewife with the
fake lips.
And to a certain extent too,
it just,
this is something more like relevant.
They became about in the last,
I feel like 15,
20 years,
which is that,
um,
being famous for the sake of being famous,
you know,
really is a curse.
You know,
it's,
it's a,
it's a highly pursued thing now where people are just like,
being famous has gotta be the best thing ever.
But when there's nothing behind the reason that you're known,
I feel like that's just an a fucking empty black hole.
But is it a mom,
as much of a black hole as growing up in poverty in a bad neighborhood in la?
Like if you look at those kids that you saw in those projects that are in this
trap,
yeah.
Was stuck in this awful neighborhood crime infested the community.
Is that a worst life or is it a war of slave to be Kim Kardashian where
everybody just shits in your mouth everywhere you go?
Well they shouldn't her mouth as she gets on a Gulf stream.
G Six 50 exactly.
No,
so it's like,
yeah.
It's like I understand the the face to do you think,
do you think to her face they're mean?
I bet they're not.
No they're not.
I bet there's a lot of apps have some mean she's had some mean things probably
yelled at her,
but there's no way people are as brutal as they are online as to her face.
No Way.
Yeah.
Even those people that are brutal to her online.
Yes.
They met her and they were in front of her.
Yeah.
That's why the,
the interaction with people online is like so flawed.
Yeah.
I was reading a mean blog about someone the other day and I was like,
I wonder what this person,
how this person would feel if there were sitting down with this guy having a
conversation with them.
Like I wonder if they would write if they would say the same type of shit that
they wrote when the person can respond.
It's like the blog writing mean blog about someone is really like the coward's
way out.
It really is in a lot of ways because you're,
you're addressing someone that can address you back in some sort of as well.
Then again,
so is shitting on them in a,
in a podcast or shitting on I'm doing stand up at least.
Well that's,
I was going to say at least we're trying to be entertaining,
but I guess they're trying to be entertaining when they write a blog too.
Yeah,
they are.
They're trying to get something out of them.
Um,
we were talking before the show about that girl who made that video about fat
shaming.
Yeah.
I only know about it because I saw a tweet,
again going back to like the entertainment of it.
Like I saw a tweet,
I saw the response video that,
uh,
Sean help and made.
I haven't seen that.
It was pretty funny.
Man Posts.
Really funny.
Let's,
let's play that.
First of all,
I watched part of the video this morning.
I,
it should have been edited.
I got,
I got her point after like the first few minutes,
but I thought it was,
it was good.
It was okay.
You know?
Yeah.
Well as she's hot,
she's hot.
That's part of the problem.
She shitting on fat people and she's got a perfect body and beautiful face and
yeah,
big old today's.
Yeah,
but this is like,
you know,
I guess she makes,
I dunno,
youtube videos,
but look,
there's a fucking business and making these goddamn youtube videos.
There are the comedy store next door.
They have that hotel where they use the side of the hotel is a billboard and
they paint stuff on it.
There's a huge one that was all just as youtube page.
So this girl that,
I don't know who she is,
but she has 2 million followers on youtube and youtube has decided to take out
giant billboards on the sunset strip that show people that have more than a
million followers.
So they have like x amount of million.
Wow.
Yeah.
And then she has more than one.
This one girl,
I don't remember her name at all,
but like it's her with like some cheese puffs on it.
You know,
it's like trying to be wacky,
but there's a,
there's several of them.
I've seen several.
So there's,
if you can be entertaining like this girl hit the fucking jackpot with this
video because we're talking about
it,
right?
It's on Twitter.
A lot of people talking about it.
Sean Halpern doesn't help.
And by the way,
I'm not Sean helping if anyone's watching the way better looking at him,
I don't give a fuck.
Everybody says let's,
let's play it.
Let's see what their response
got my Kisha here today.
You don't know if this is hairspray or semen?
No.
Pretty sure that seaman,
dear fat people.
Yes.
What do you have to tell us?
Some people are already really mad at this video
cause I'm mad about your shitty act outs.
What are you gonna do?
I'm going to sit here and wait for you to tell me a hacky fat joke.
What do you do?
Wait,
what are you going to chase me?
Really?
You're gonna Chase me?
Yeah.
Nope.
I only chase after Taco trucks and people that are relevant.
It's going to be like fucking Frankenstein.
Frankenstein wasn't fat.
He was slow.
Oh.
Oh,
I see what you're doing.
You're comparing.
Someone took a comedy class.
Yeah.
Can you act out being a Zombie so we can get the whole side by crowd and nerds
behind you.
I can get away from you by walking at a reasonable pace.
Is that a snake?
Oh No,
it's just your list.
Frankenstein not so fast.
Zombies have apparently gotten faster.
Oh,
we're talking about zombies now you're way off from your original message.
I watch like three episodes of the walking dead and not being slow myself and
the gray goods.
Yeah,
so I'm looking at
realize that every single episode is exactly the same.
What you mean killing zombies?
That's what the show is about.
Dot.
Me.
Oh No.
They need something,
but it's all the way over there.
Where the zombies?
Yes,
because that's what the show is about.
And why is this being shot like an American apparel ad?
That shit
shaming.
It's not a thing.
Okay.
Why don't you tell that to the teenagers to kill theirself?
Because people were fat shaming them.
Yeah.
Oh,
you can't cause your dad.
Oh Shit.
It's probably made up.
Wow.
Why made up by the same person who told you you have talent?
That's the race card with no race.
Now you're bringing race into it.
Oh,
and can I get a shitty act out?
Yeah,
but I couldn't fit into a store.
That's discrimination now then that means you're too fat and you should stop
beating it,
right?
Hey,
can someone shut this bitch up?
Drop that shitty act out.
Everybody just needs to make laws.
There's a race car is a disability card.
There was even a gay card
race card,
a disability card.
A gay card is bitch better not have a sag card.
All right,
good harvest from an to guest wrongfully so
no,
the gate car's covered in glitter.
It's fucking magical.
Oh,
hope you choke on a glow stick.
Hope somebody beat you with a Unicorn.
Hope somebody takes those three cards you're talking about and shoves him up.
I ain't going to tell a doctor that they're being mean and fat shaming you when
they say you have fucking heart disease.
No,
because he's a professional and he's saying it to my face.
He's not on social media making dumb blanket statement.
I'm not talking about people who have a little bit of cushion.
For the pushing and if there's people watching this with a specific health
condition,
this is not aimed at you.
You just talked about someone who might have heart disease.
You talking about the 35% of North Americans who are old piece spell
obese.
I dare you.
You are affecting your
doctor,
but I bet you played one in a porno phone,
isn't the thing.
Never said.
Okay.
Yeah,
that sounds great.
Yeah.
Well that's what happens when you make something like that,
right?
Yeah.
If you open yourself up to that dude,
when you make anything,
no,
you're out,
but you're like,
you know what?
I've what?
Whoa.
Does that say Damon Wayans Defense Bill Cosby?
Yeah.
You didn't hear about that.
Shut the fuck.
Oh,
you should have here.
Hold on a second.
What is that?
Hold on.
Oh,
this is,
he was on the breakfast club the other day.
I'm on.
Just pull it.
Pull that up too.
That's,
that was it.
That can't be real.
It was just on the headline thing.
You know they have that little headline thing.
Dropdown.
Yeah,
the dropdown,
I guess.
Entertainment.
Go to entertainment.
Cecil.
The lion killers back to it.
There it is.
Damon Wayans defense bill Cosby after this where he calls his accusers
unrapable.
Oh no,
he didn't say.
Yeah.
No,
you know who else defended him?
Who Chuck d?
Chuck d called them the all the accusations against doctor Cosby.
That's what he said.
Doctor Cosby.
Which by the,
by the way,
first of all,
he's not a fucking doctor.
It's an honorary doctorate.
He can't call him doctor Cosby.
When a university gives you an honorary doctorate for fucking showing up and
being nice is,
it gives a lot of attention and promotion.
The chuck to do that.
Recently,
very recently.
Really?
I was shocked.
It was talking about that the conspiracy against doctor cause him on.
No,
I'm not.
I'm not kidding.
And I'm a huge Chuck d fan.
Huge public enemy fan.
But I don't know man.
Fuck man.
Tell the truth.
Wayne said about his advice for the Cosby show.
Star.
If I was him,
I would divorce my wife,
give her all my money and then I would go do a deposition.
I would light one of those three hours cigars and have some wine and maybe
equate list
and I would just go off,
cause I don't believe that he was raping.
I believe he was in relationships with all of them.
And then he was like,
you know what?
It's 78.
It don't work like that no more.
I can't get it up for any y'all by bitches.
And then they're like,
oh really?
Rape.
It was he just trying to be funny.
It's hard.
It's hard to know.
Yeah.
Okay.
Power one oh five,
his breakfast club.
Is that,
that Dude Charlemagne?
Yeah.
That guy is like,
his whole show is like talking shit and I'm like,
yeah,
fine.
The God.
Yeah.
So he's just trying to probably be,
wait,
good.
He called it the money hustle.
I think he should listen to this.
I,
this is one of those things where I definitely don't,
there should have audio
of it.
Let's play the audio because I don't think like I'm doing it a shitty version of
it cause uh,
it's just like,
I don't think that he,
um,
you know,
I can't,
I have a really hard time believing that you actually said that.
That's fucking crazy
is fine.
The actual a thing of it and then we'll uh,
we'll go back to it.
Do you have the ability to only have the audio in your head so you can listen to
it?
Know what the fuck kind of a studio that we have here,
Jamie,
we need to do,
if you put,
if you type in breakfast club,
will it?
Well,
I think he found it.
He just has to
isolate the audio.
That's crazy.
Like I said that though she's dead is career suicide because then he also,
he also was like,
yeah,
I'll just let you play.
It was,
it was pretty crazy.
Did you hear it?
I read it.
I read a full like transcript.
I didn't hear it.
It's hard because Damon is really funny.
Damon Wayans is one of the most underrated comedians,
like almost ever Damon Waynes at one point in time.
I know he got off of it and decided to like do more acting.
He was in the last boy scout.
He had made some like really big movies and he was doing real well and it was
coming off of in living color and he was on his way to,
he was on his way to superstar them to the point where he did um,
one,
one of his HBO specials,
I think it was called Damon Waynes last stand.
And when it was over he threw the mic down and say like,
this is my last stand up.
I'm ever going to do a little maybe through the mic down and walked away.
And I remember thinking like,
you can't stop.
Like you're so good.
He's one of my favorites at the time he was like one of my all time favorites
and I just,
you don't hear him doing standup that much anymore?
You don't hear of it.
I did a show though.
Um,
it was like probably nine months ago at flappers and then they're like,
hey,
uh,
cause it wasn't like my show that,
do you mind if Damon Waynes does a spot next?
Hold on,
hold on,
hold on.
And I go,
no.
And he came in and just did a spot before,
you know right after me.
Oh yeah,
it's fun.
Yeah.
But before you,
that guy does long sets.
Like he used to,
he used to show up at the comedy store and like at the height of his fame he
would go up and do like 45 minutes out of nowhere he was doing like,
um,
he was really doing a workout set,
like a real workout set.
And it was really funny.
Like it wasn't like fully polished bits yet,
but it was a really funny,
no,
he fucks around a lot.
He takes a lot of chances.
Yeah.
He's funny man.
He,
I used to see him a lot when I was coming up at the comedy store in the 90s.
And a,
he would come by and do those long sets.
And this was like,
like I said,
at the height of his stardom.
But I think the Sitcom world lured,
lured him away man.
Cause that was crazy money cause that he had that.
What was that last time that he did that ran for like a while?
It ran for a wildlife and kids or something that that ran for a while,
but nobody gave a fuck about it.
No,
I mean I'm sure the people watching it might've given a fuck about it,
but in comparison to like what he's capable of with a standard.
Yeah.
No
cause a monster.
He's a monster.
He could have been,
I think one of the all time greats.
I really do believe that.
I think he could been like Chapelle.
I think it could have been right up there with all those guys who were as strong
when you're,
imagine what his quote was.
I just going into that stupid stupid money.
Yeah.
And you know it's fucking hard,
man.
Did they get lured into that?
Or Boy,
who knows?
Man.
Maybe he just decided that that's what he wanted to do.
Maybe the idea of doing standup all the time wasn't appealing.
Tim.
I don't know man.
You know?
Yeah.
But it's just,
I see a guy like that and I go,
wow,
that's kind of crazy cause he's like easily one of the all times
during the day,
back in the day and then you see them now and just never hear about them
anymore.
I never hear about him like doing like a stadium somewhere or they they said,
I mean I don't know if this was true,
but I remember hearing multiple,
we'll talk say that Eddie Murphy when he stopped doing standup was saying that
like I don't want to even have to compete with Daymond weights.
Like I heard people say that,
that that's what Eddie Murphy thought of Damon Wayans that he was like that's,
it was the funniest fucking guy.
He was so good dude.
I remember seeing him nights at the comedy store with like 50 people in the
audience just rushing.
Yeah.
And be inspired thinking,
fuck this one of those good,
natural,
like it's overused term,
but he's just naturally funny guy.
Right?
Like he's a guy.
I feel like that could just kind of talk about anything.
It'd be funny.
Well he works at it for sure.
I mean it's hard to say naturally funny when the guy's doing sets all the time.
True.
You know,
we all know that that's the way it,
everything is polished up.
But yeah,
I had heard that.
I don't know if that's true,
so I probably shouldn't be saying it,
but I had heard that he had installed a stage in his house.
Come on.
Yeah.
That he put a stage like he installed like a little mini comedy club in his
house.
I like to fuck around and practice.
Really?
Yeah.
That sounds crazy.
It,
it does sound crazy,
but why is that crazy?
But someone installing a music studio in their house isn't crazy.
It's true.
I get,
because I think it's the idea that you need like pretty much strangers to be at
your comedy show.
You know,
like you need an audience or a studio.
It's where you do your work.
Doesn't matter where it's located.
Like are you just going to have people like Rsvp to my house this weekend,
man?
Well maybe he would practice in front of nobody and maybe he would have his
family sit down.
Listen,
Oh,
who the fuck knows?
Yeah,
at privacy front and nobody's kind of a weird thing,
right?
Like I've heard people tell me a lot of times I've heard people go,
hey man,
I'm trying to get into stand up.
Like what should I do?
And I'm like,
well you know,
get on stage.
Like I do it a lot.
I'm like,
where do you do it?
Like at home,
stay standing in front of the mirror and do it there.
I'm like,
Oh yeah,
you need it when you need an audience.
Man.
I recorded all my ideas like as standup bits before I ever did them.
It had like a tape recorder when those little press buttons and your record.
But it was,
you know,
when I was,
I never even did stand up yet.
So it was my idea of what standup should
sound like the mind.
Where are those tapes?
I'd love to get ahold of that.
Or is everybody doing?
How's everybody?
Oh,
it was awful.
I'm sure.
But I only did it like before.
I did stand out.
Once I got did my first open mic night,
I stopped doing it.
Do you record ideas still in New York?
Like your phone's yes,
I'll record ideas,
but more often than that instead of recording,
um,
I do record them,
but I talk into the voice thing.
I talking to,
uh,
this,
you know,
you have the voice,
the voice notes or the,
um,
the notes APP.
You know,
you could talk to it.
No.
Oh Dude.
Check this out.
She,
this little button right here.
Yeah.
Thomson Gora is a bad motherfucker.
Bam.
Oh,
that's a notes.
Yup.
How the fuck am I haven't ever dumb it.
Oh,
it's amazing.
So I'm in my car.
If I'm in my car and I have an idea,
I'll either record it well,
which I'll sometimes do or I will just say the note and it will type it out for
you.
But there's some,
there's some stuff that's lost and like writing things down as opposed to like
hearing it.
So did you isolate what he said?
Okay.
Joe Rogan just taught me how this shit works.
Oh Man.
And then amazing.
It's so accurate now.
Yeah,
it would.
Yeah.
What advice would you give bill Cosby now if you could tell him this is what you
need to do.
He say die.
Die.
I,
if I was him,
I would divorce my wife,
wink,
give all my money and then I would go do a deposition at light,
one of them three hours cigars.
I have me some why and maybe a quail Lu and I would just go off because I don't
believe that he was raping.
I think he was in relationships with all of them.
And then he's like,
you know what?
It's 70 80 don't work no more.
I can't get it up for any of y'all buy bitches.
And how they'd like,
Oh really?
Rape.
Because I mean the 40 year relationships with 40 years,
you listen,
how big is his penis that it give you Amnesia for 40 years?
Whoa.
No.
And often is some women did come out previously,
Dan,
go ahead previously and come out and give their stories and we didn't hear is a
couple of them,
right?
That did,
you know,
decades.
A couple of decades ago.
So yeah,
but he never was charged with anything.
Right.
But if you listen to them talk,
they go,
well,
the
first time,
the first time bitch,
how many times did it happen?
This listen to what they're saying.
And some of them really,
it's unreasonable when you look,
look at them and go,
no,
wait,
not one debt,
Yay.
And Charlemagne,
yeah,
to here.
No,
but I am.
Then the dynamics that might've been hot,
but I understand the dynamic of people saying,
well why were you alone with him?
Or why were you in that room?
Or why did you go upstairs with him?
And then people,
people look at you in a certain way and you're like,
man,
maybe I shouldn't have done that.
Maybe that's my fault.
Look,
I understand fame.
I've lived it.
Women will throw themselves at you.
They want,
you know,
they just want to be in New York presence.
This some that innocently will come up.
They're putting out 40 something women.
They're not that naive.
He talked about in 1965 he just walked in someone's dressing room in and put his
penis in your mouth.
But then people who are also looking at bill Cosby and the persona that he has,
if like a mentor,
I'm going to help you with your career.
And some of them were on the Cosby show and we come into his dressing room cause
we did wrong.
He start criticizing young black men.
Yup.
And then he lost us.
And so we're not supporting him and they see that opening and so now you know
what attack him,
kill him.
But the dude from seventh heaven,
his shows still on TV.
Yup.
That's very true.
What you said because Woody Allen making sure,
oh is that dude from seventh heaven?
So show still on TV.
I thought they pulled that.
I don't know if it was pause that real quick then I would,
is that,
I think it's cool they got pulled a while ago.
I thought,
yeah.
Is that true?
One that actually I remember when that was 77 guy,
he calms.
Right.
He actually admitted that he raped young girls.
He admitted that he had sexually molested young girls.
Yeah.
Oh,
let's see.
Seventh Heaven canceled.
Well,
they stopped.
I thought they even stopped airing the reruns.
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure seventh heaven was canceled.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's canceled.
Yeah.
But that guy is not in jail.
Right.
Don't know.
I don't know.
Stephen Collins is his name.
Let's see.
Steve Collins.
But I think,
uh,
yeah,
confesses sexual abuse,
but that's December.
Yeah.
The last news of this was from over a year ago.
Wow.
So it just,
that's it.
He got divorced.
He's divorced.
This is the last,
um,
piece of news is that he got divorced,
is divorced,
settled,
and then his confession tape.
Wasn't that a part of the divorce?
Like the part of like why he got caught was that his wife,
he recorded it.
I recorded it and she outdid him because she was divorcing him.
Well,
who knows why she didn't,
I hope she,
you know,
I hope she felt like he was a piece of shit and I was part of the reasons
Washington it sediment,
a 50 50 split as we previous reported the pot is worth around 14 million bucks.
I,
I had 14 million bucks.
What the hell man?
Imagine.
Imagine the poor
woman live homeless guy and he's fucking little kids kids.
God dammit.
Yeah.
That guy should be,
it says the tape has made him unemployable and therefore he should be socked
with a big spousal support tab.
Oh goodness.
But they worked it out down to who got the front of drawing or the guy should be
in jail period.
Right.
Just in jail.
But this Cosby thing like Damon Wayans attitude about it is very strange.
I don't agree with them at all.
No,
I mean the heat by what he said also what he said about Cosby criticizing young
black men.
That's fucking absolutely the truth.
He should have shut his fucking mouth about that.
But he should have shut his fucking mouth about that.
Not because he was raping women just because it's none of your fucking business.
Like who who swears or who doesn't swear you're denying the artistic integrity
of like Richard Pryor or Dave Chappelle or any of these guys who swear.
I think he's also making a commentary about that.
Cosby was doing it to young black men in society because that was a big thing
for him in like the last,
the last 1520 year,
he even wrote a book with another guy,
but he was like,
you know that famous like pull your pants,
put something to you have these ridiculous names.
He gave like that kind of town hall speech and he went into like really
impoverished areas and he's like,
these names that you guys are,
these aren't real names like right pooky.
Yeah,
like what's his Kwan Tasha.
Oh,
so when he started to do that,
people were like,
well,
here's a,
a Uber rich dude coming in telling us how to live our life.
Right.
Telling us we're doing everything wrong.
He lost a lot of fans with that.
I don't,
I think he's definitely got a point with that.
But then when he,
the other thing,
the woman had a point about how Cosby had that mentor role.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
He would,
uh,
he would have these people and say,
who's going to help their career?
That's what they all said.
Could you imagine though,
if you were a young girl,
like some 18 year old girl and Bill Cosby who is,
you know,
50 or 60 at the time,
whatever the hell he was,
it brings you into his dressing room,
says it's going to help your career and then slips a fucking quail food into
your drink and you're passed out and you wake up with your panties off and
Cosby's just dripping down your asshole.
And you're like,
what dude?
Yeah.
You'd be so confused and so horrifying and you know,
no one's going to believe you too.
That's,
that's by the way,
the whole thing about,
like,
I've heard a lot of people bring up the,
uh,
the,
the time between something happening in the accusation,
very common with sexual assault to wait long periods of time because people feel
shame and they feel like no one will believe them.
They don't know what to do.
It's really common.
It's not unusual at all.
When that's the case with,
uh,
all rape.
Right,
right.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
Like all the sexual sex crimes,
a lot of times don't go reported.
Yeah.
It's the,
the idea that
they're Annrai bubble that he's trying to be funny.
Yeah.
He was trying to be fine there.
We see that.
It was only like,
do you want to keep going?
Sure.
Okay.
The guilt bill got,
but at,
but being just sit back looking at it,
I just go,
I just don't believe this.
I think it's a money house.
What'd you say is true social media where the loudest on social media and social
media is what really reignited?
Definitely back a vandal blueberries.
Yup.
I wonder how he feels being the dude that destroyed Bill Cup.
He should be [inaudible] bill got to be done.
He should be charged with assessory the murder
shut up,
man.
And for them to make those ideas.
That's something that was kind of like,
well known.
You know,
people heard that about bill Cosby.
I remember when I was really young.
My Mom told me that she knew somebody that a bill Cosby had drugged and she told
me that when she got that back up too.
But it is a story that had always floated around.
That's what I think.
But here's the thing,
I don't know.
I believe every single fifth of the 50 women,
but I do believe that
there is some,
there may be an end for them.
My heart goes out to them.
Anybody who was sure and I hope you get justice.
You are the bitches.
Look,
he gave me two pills.
Ain't nobody,
he's,
he wasn't a doctor back then.
It was like that was the drug of choice.
Like Molly's his drug of choice now.
You know like people do that to get in the mood,
you know,
I just,
I don't,
I can't grow Nando nobody never told him.
Yes you got him drunk.
They woke up.
But what's the joy of sleeping,
you know,
banging somebody who's asleep.
Got It.
Well,
and you know,
people,
people have done that to date thing.
You know
what,
what do you think about Hannibal Birth?
I wouldn't
want to be him.
I know because you know,
he,
the thing is he,
you know,
I watch his show and I don't think he,
um,
it's premature in terms of his success right now.
They've putting him out there because you know of the guy who had to move out of
the bill Cosby and he wouldn't primetime [inaudible] you know,
me.
So hopefully maybe he'll get it,
you know,
he'll,
he'll catch it,
but I don't feel it right now and I,
you know,
I wouldn't want to be someone to take down my hero.
Right.
I think we need heroes and I think that we need to be more supportive until we
know for sure.
For sure.
Because ain't no charges against him.
You know,
innocent till proven guilty.
Not In this day and age with social media,
guilty.
You guilty ones what it says.
Right.
And they don't ever date,
they never retract what they say.
No,
they just put that on you.
You know,
that's a,
that's a heavy one to carry around.
I
think the bigger thing here,
never this,
looking at anything,
anything could happen.
And when it could be like,
oh I told him no,
I keep my draws on.
They never had a baby pinned on you.
Really up to rape women is bill Cosby's.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
The thing that people,
I think they struggle with too with this whole cost we story is that like when
he said hero he was a hero to so many people.
That's,
that's the part that they,
cause they can't wrap their head around.
This was like if you're here as a piece of shit though,
don't you want a new hero?
Yeah.
But I think it's,
it's so beat in like the hero thing is so deep in their mind they don't want to
believe that the heroes a piece of shit.
There's a problem also that there's people that are really bad people that do
really good things as well.
Oh right.
There's,
there's people that are inconsistent.
I mean they do great things.
Like you might be a great comic but also be a rapist.
Yeah.
It might be really drugging women and raping them as well as being really funny.
That might be his demon.
Cause like almost every comic has some sort of a demon,
whether it's an anger demon or a drug demon or a violence demon or a gambling
demon or a,
you know,
whatever the fuck the demon is.
His demon might very well be.
He likes to drunk people.
He likes to have that ultimate power.
And you know,
there's other,
the other knock on bill Cosby has always been that he's a massive elitist where
he believes he's much better than everybody else.
Right.
It's always been the knock on him.
And to the point where I worked at a casino where he wanted people to tuck him
in bed at night,
he wanted the security guard to tuck him in bed.
Like literally.
Really?
Yup.
He likes to be tucked in bed.
He wanted people to sit down and watch him.
They wanted all the staff that was working in the theater to watch him eat
curry.
Like this is not something that I,
I'm the only one who's heard this too.
I've read this online too that he would,
he likes the people that work there to sit down with him while he eats and they
don't talk to them.
The venue where they told you that?
Yes,
that he sits down there,
he needs and they all sit around and watch me and he wants them to do that.
Like he hit a god complex,
whatever it is,
whatever craziness that allowed him to be that guy that openly criticized
people.
You ever see that Taiwan,
Wanda Sykes interviewed him some,
some award show or something like that and he just,
he's like,
yeah,
get on her English.
He,
while he's wearing sunglasses indoors and he had that arrogance about him.
Right.
That's the same kind of arrogance.
It would make you feel like you're better than other people to the point where
you could just drug them.
You know,
especially some young girl that you might think it's stupid and you get his drug
or like this is silly bitch back at my place,
thinks
she's not going to give that pussy to bill Cosby.
Plink plink here,
drink.
This was like a Cappuccino.
Yeah.
Keep you awake.
I mean how ironic.
It's given him Cappuccino with fucking Queloz ludes in it.
Here's a Sam and then that.
I keep hearing people,
they keep saying,
um,
what's like,
what fun is it to fuck somebody that's asleep?
It's because that's what he likes.
He likes raping people that are asleep.
It's not about hooking up because you're famous.
That's a crazy thing to say because what fun is it to rape someone who's
resisting?
We're saying that that doesn't happen every.
Of course,
of course.
I'm saying what Cosby likes is he likes raping passed out people.
Right.
What I'm saying is and how ridiculous is the,
anyone's sang that.
Right?
Right,
right.
That's so short sighted.
I know.
It is.
What fun is it Robin People?
Yeah.
Don't you want to get your own money?
Yeah,
of course.
Done the same thing is it is.
It's the same.
It's just,
it's such a short sighted thing to say.
It's,
it's a type of thing that someone says when they're not talking to really
intelligent,
objective people on a regular basis.
Right.
Formulating these opinions based on real extensive thinking,
you know,
and the idea that all of them are alliance seems kind of crazy.
Yeah.
It just seems kind of course it's crazy.
Fucking crime.
I mean this isn't like,
this isn't something small.
This isn't like a guy who,
uh,
you know,
Bill Cosby stared at my wife's tits.
He's checking my wife's tits to now this is like some deep,
deep,
dark demonic shit.
And then they're going to blame like the have the blame beyond Hannibal.
Like it's like he did so stupid.
Also them saying that Hannibal got that show just because that handle was a hot
already hot,
which is why,
which is why people were coming to see his show in a theater.
A theater show.
Yeah.
While he was talking about bill Cosby course.
So this is not a small thing.
And Hannibal's argument was about,
Bill Cosby always shits on people for using bad language,
which is fucking true.
It was,
was the whole thing we were talking about like how he was lecturing exact black
Pete.
Exactly.
And Hannah was like,
well Lewis,
I'm a fucking rapist and put that fucking phone down,
Tommy.
Flip it over and I see what you're doing.
I see what you can get out.
I shut my phone.
I shut my computer for you.
Thank you.
I just don't want to,
I don't want to influence you in any way.
Thank you.
It's,
it's hard,
right?
It's kind of hard.
I think that the guy is a sick fuck.
That's what I think.
I think undeniably he's a sick fuck.
How sick of a fuck he is,
how evil he is.
The only people that know are him and the people that he did that too.
It's the best profile ever for somebody that wants to do that.
So the,
the,
if you,
if you take away what you know of him as a performer and the celebrity and
you're just,
imagine somebody that wants to do that and then they build a reputation of being
someone you can trust.
Impeccable,
impeccable.
I mean,
he had the best reputation ever.
You know,
it's,
it's like when you,
like when you have,
uh,
the,
the Sandusky Guy,
the coach that had a charity that was for kids
and then,
and he was like,
I'm taking care of these kids that are,
um,
you know,
left behind and um,
and then he was raping those kids.
But people that were people that even knew him that were on the board of that,
we're like,
he's the best guy is apparently very common that one of the things that evil
people will do is they'll start a charity and then like really harp on that
charity.
Let's talk about that charity all the time.
And they become a,
almost a beyond reproach because the fact they're doing such good work,
right?
Like one of the things Lance Armstrong used to always bring up is how much money
he was generating for cancer research.
Of course,
we're,
we're trying to,
we've generated all this money for,
instead of saying action,
except instead of saying like,
Hey,
uh,
no,
I didn't,
I'm not doing any steroids.
No one's doing steroids,
which he did say a few times.
Yeah.
Or he would like immediately go to that thing about like,
like how much money we're making with live strong.
And it was people's defense for him all the time.
Yeah.
I,
when I criticized him on this show,
I got lit up by people.
This was before he can and they were like,
has he ever failed a test?
Like his whole thing.
I've never failed a test.
And do you realize the amount of money being funneled into cancer research?
It's like that excuses.
It's as is all fucked up.
I had Jeff Novitsky on the guy who busted him and uh,
um,
after he was on,
uh,
lance contacted me and had a conversation with him on the phone and uh,
Lance Armstrong contacted and he may or may not do the podcast because he wants
to tell his story.
I think if I look at his point of view,
I think he was in a sport where everybody was doing drugs.
Right.
And I think there's a moment when you have these ideals,
like what you're trying to do as a competitor and then you get to the big
leagues and you realize like you get into that NFL locker room when you find out
why people are 350 pounds of solid muscle.
Yeah.
You're like,
oh,
I get it.
Like I have a buddy who played,
I don't know what to say,
what college you played for,
but he played college for um,
he played football.
He's a big fucking dude.
And he played with a bunch of guys who were in the NFL now he had some injuries
and he stopped playing.
He said that when he got to college,
he goes,
there was this attitude that you only have a few years,
you have a couple of years to make an impression.
And he said the fucking sophistication of the drug use that he saw when he was
in college in a big,
big time college football team.
He goes,
it was fucking crazy.
it was crazy.
And it was widespread and it was from the top down.
Everybody knew what the fuck was going on.
And there was an established protocol and they would tell you,
hey buddy,
you're going to get tested on Friday,
so on Friday,
come in and,
and you know,
you're going to have to take your test.
And he said,
when he would get tested,
they would say,
okay,
here's your cop.
Um,
you know,
so go in there,
uh,
do your urine sample and then come out and bring it to me.
Like there was no one there while he did it.
No one watched.
They didn't tell if he had a rubber dick to didn't tell if he had a guy in there
waiting for him to piss in it for him.
He goes,
I could have had my cousin pissing a thing for me.
People would piss in bags and they would take that bag and strap it to their
body so it keep it body temperature and then put it onto your clothes.
And then you would,
uh,
get into the bathroom and you open up that bag and pour the contents into the,
the thing.
Sure.
So you'd have someone else's Piss.
He said,
but they gave you all the time in the world to do it and he goes and everybody,
everybody,
everybody was doing steroids.
Every buddy he goes,
they weren't just doing steroids.
They would do an EPO.
They were doing all these drugs to maximize your endurance that we do in all
these recovery drugs they were doing.
He goes,
they were doing everything.
Everybody's doing everything.
I believe it.
I totally believe,
I believe it too,
and I think that's what happened with Lance Armstrong.
I think this guy gotten into cycling.
Yeah.
He got to the highest level of the sport and he got to the pros and he's like,
Oh shit.
This is all about taking your own blood out and putting it back in your body.
There's about doing EPO.
This is about doing testosterone.
This is about doing whatever the fuck you can do to recover so that you can
compete and then you've got the US Postal Service.
Okay.
Which is the,
the guys who are promoting his,
his event,
right?
He's warm.
He's the cyclist for the postal team.
So now he's getting sued for not just the money that they paid him for winning
because you don't,
you have to sign something saying that you're on drugs.
But because he was working for the government,
they say he's defrauded the government.
So the,
they can sue you for three times the damages Jesus.
So they're suing them for $100 million right now.
Yeah,
it's pretty well the thing about,
I think what he did too,
and that like the why the perception is,
you know,
different for lands in particular is that the light was shining brighter because
of how successful he was and then the way that he would defend himself,
he was fucking vicious about it.
So people to sue people and then take them down publicly.
Like he was destroying people's ability to work,
make money,
support their families.
So it,
he was,
he was cold fucking blooded about defending himself,
which made him basically like a bigger dick throughout the whole thing.
So not just the cheater,
but a guy that was really fucking an asshole to everybody on the way.
That's what I want to hear.
A story.
Yeah.
I want to hear how he views it and I also want to hear what it was like to be
the focus of attention for a fucking dirty industry.
I mean,
it's a dirty business.
Do you watch the documentary?
I did.
What was it like talking to him?
Interesting.
How long did you do I start for awhile.
Yeah.
And we talked for a while on the phone.
I haven't met him in person.
I was in Austin.
I was going to invite them to my show,
but I'm like,
Eh,
probably better.
Just talk to him when I see him.
If,
if and when I,
Sam just talked to he considering doing?
Yeah,
his idea.
He reached out to me.
Wow.
Yeah.
I think,
well listen,
you're not going to get a platform like this where you're going to reach
millions of people and you can talk for three hours and I want to let you say
anything you want.
Yeah.
And I'm gonna,
I'm gonna.
I want,
I want him to express himself as openly and as look.
It's all on the table now.
They sue the shit out of him.
They took a fuck load of money from them.
They took away his ability to make a living.
I mean,
he's a guy that was the poster boy for this sport.
if it wasn't for him,
who gives a fuck about cycling?
You got Greg Lamont and you got Lance Armstrong and that's it.
I don't know anybody else.
Do you know one other guy was cycles?
No,
I know Tony Hawk.
I don't know anybody else at skateboards.
Right?
Who the fuck out skateboard?
I'm sure there's other guys,
but that's the guy that's the big name guy.
You know what I mean?
There's a lot of sports that have that like women's fighting.
Everybody knows who Ronda Rousey is.
There's a million other women fighters.
It's so big.
She's so big now that like I was in,
uh,
I was in a hotel on fight night when she fought less and like just dudes that
you know are not fans of women's athletics.
We're all,
you know what I mean?
They're all walking around.
Just,
I've just to tell you how,
like,
how much she's changed things.
Like they were like walking look and talking to like the bell bellhop.
Where's the rousy fight on?
I got to go find the right.
Like I feel like that's how much it swung,
you know,
and she's changed it where like these fucking total misogynistic pigs,
we're still like,
I need to find that Rousey for.
Why would you assume that?
Just because they're dudes that their massages dick pig.
I just,
I'm an asshole.
Because you're a guy.
Yeah.
I just looked at them and I was like,
these guys are pigs.
Yeah,
for sure.
If they like sports and they work out their pigs there,
these guys were pigs.
These guys didn't work out.
Yeah.
Did you see what Beyonce did?
Beyonce did the central park concert.
It was a free concert and uh,
Dana white came up to me Saturday and after the fights and he pulls over his
iPhone.
He goes,
watch this.
Not The flip phone.
No,
he has an iPhone now.
They make them use the iPhone because he's under some investigation.
So they have to be able to try and call her shit because of his,
uh,
they're getting sued because a bunch of shit going on.
Anyway.
He,
uh,
shows me this video,
on his iPhone and it's a,
Beyonce has a free concert in central park and on this giant screens fucking
enormous.
A hundred foot screen.
She has all Ronda Rousey's words playing out like the script of it while Ron is
talking,
Ron is talking about not being a do nothing bitch.
She's like,
every muscle in my body has a functional purpose.
I'm not some do nothing bitch sitting around waiting for some millionaire to
come home.
Fuck me.
And which like to like chick that hustle chicks that hustle that is like,
they are like,
yeah,
fuck yeah.
But to all those do nothing pitches out there that's like,
Hey,
what the fuck?
I mean I don't want to work.
I went like,
we're trying to get lucrative.
I ain't trying to hustle that hard.
How lucrative are you willing to get?
Cause I get lucrative.
I get pretty lucrative.
That's amazing.
Is that a shirt next week?
I'm trying to get a little quick.
I,
uh,
I retweeted Ian Edwards.
Uh,
his,
uh,
you know,
he's a appearance this weekend at the punchline.
By the way,
if you're in Sacramento,
he's one of the funniest fucking dude's is working today.
Fucking funny.
Look good.
He wrote me after I tweeted to him.
Thanks man.
It's going to be lucrative.
We're both laughing about it as a play.
How lucrative do you get?
Cause I kept pretty low.
I you be lucrative.
He,
um,
when I was in Montreal,
I think I told you this,
I did a show every night,
an hour show every night.
Right.
So I would just ask,
I asked Tony to come by and like just to an opening set,
you know?
Right.
Dude in fucking floored the place.
He's a monster.
Yeah.
He floored it.
And he's only doing that now.
I mean,
he's doing some writing,
but he's really concentrating on that.
Let's see.
That's it.
And that's how you get really good.
We had a conversation about a man.
I,
I told him,
I said,
dude,
I think you're one of the best goddamn comics in the world.
I think you one of the best comics on the planet earth and people don't know
about you.
I go the,
the difference between your skill level,
your ability and what people know is so vast.
And it's because he's been writing so much writing on all these sitcoms and he's
got it.
He's very good at that.
But he's best at stand up his standup and he's a monster.
He's such an,
uh,
like a unique original voice.
Yeah.
Know people that don't,
one reminds me of him.
Like he's,
he's really a unique talent and he's such a good dude.
Yeah.
I've been friends with him for like 24 years,
23 years.
He's got that fucking non aging black guy thing where I'm like,
what are you,
he won't tell me how old he is.
Well,
yeah,
and then you go,
like,
I was in New York at a club,
I forget where I,
which club I was in and he had a fucking head shot on there that looked 25 years
old and he had dreads.
And I was like,
how old is this shit,
man?
How old is he?
Uh,
he's a vampire bro.
Yeah,
he's advanced flips upside down.
Yeah.
Um,
let me see how old he is.
We'll find out.
I'm really not right now.
I'm going to Wikipedia the fucker.
That shit that's probably not on there.
Right.
It says he's only 43 it says he was born February 11th,
1972 43.
Okay.
That's bullshit.
Unless he was 15 when I met him.
No.
Yeah.
So that's a lie.
And how dare you.
But he might,
that might be true.
He won't tell you though.
If you ask him,
he won't tell you the stripper or that we've talked to.
She wouldn't tell us either.
I go,
how old are you?
I'm 48.
How old you?
I'm like come on lady.
Never tells her age.
I'm like yeah they do when they're 20.
Yeah.
Oh and can't believe.
And then I get now I don't ever knock it sir.
I used to not get sort of
that much.
Yeah.
Brain your beard son.
And I'm,
you get the fuck out of here.
That man's beer.
Sorry sir.
We'll be with you in a minute sir.
I'm like,
alright,
you gotta fucking Werewolf Beard and he would with a big ass gorilla beard like
that.
Or are sir.
Yeah,
for sure.
Absolutely.
Your goddamn man Tommy Buttons.
Yeah,
your man about to make a baby while you made a baby.
I may have to have a baby a couple of months away.
How's that feel?
I'm excited,
man.
I really am.
I think it's part of the reason is that,
uh,
I think it's because I didn't have a baby at 25,
you know,
so it's like something that I waited while we waited obviously,
and then you're more established.
I feel more like financially stable and emotionally ready for it,
so,
well,
it's perfect.
It's a perfect time.
I hear people go like,
is it,
are you terrified?
And I'm like,
no.
That's people that don't want any commitment in their life.
Yeah.
I'm not terrified at all.
Those guys probably don't even have girlfriends.
All right.
Yeah,
I guess I never thought about it,
but I'm like,
no,
I'm excited for it.
I'm not terrified.
These people that can't imagine anybody living other than the way they live.
Right.
You know?
But you'll,
you'll get that from all sides.
People.
Are you ready for your life to be over?
What?
Who said that to you?
Just caught them off whatever they are.
Yeah.
Right.
Life to be over the,
you know what's equally annoying?
No,
and I got to say,
I really found this very knowing when I was single and I didn't have kids.
It didn't really bug the shit out of me that people would tell me that you have
to have kids in order to be like a mature adult.
Like when are you going to settle down enough kids when you're going to,
when are you going to like guys that I knew that had kids that were fucking
miserable.
And by the way,
every one who told me this to a man,
everyone is divorced.
Yeah.
Every single one.
Every single one that told me to get married and have children is fucking
divorced.
Yeah.
Every one of them.
I'm going to like seven,
eight,
nine guys.
Yeah.
I've,
I've never believed that.
I certainly never lectured to is shit telling people to live their lives the way
you're living your life.
When it can.
Only way you can do it.
Everybody's got to waste.
A lot of people are weird man.
Some people they just want it.
Like I have a friend,
my friend Steve Maxwell,
he doesn't have a place to live.
He just travels.
He goes from town to town.
He's a a really famous as far as that world strength and conditioning coach and
a like a personal trainer and he goes all over the world like you will,
you'll see his Instagram,
he's in Fiji sometimes just training people,
training people.
He'll put together these little small seminars.
The small groups of people will meet them every week.
Like they'll say,
okay,
like you know,
they have some things set up with like 10 people we'll meet,
you know,
in this one place.
And then he's going to coach them for like five or six days.
So they have like a getaway and he puts these together and then Jim's,
we'll have them come in and he'll teach seminars at their gyms and he just lives
out of a bag.
I couldn't live like that,
but he can write.
But I would never lecture that guy.
Wouldn't,
I wouldn't like it,
but he can do it.
Sure.
Tom Rhodes for the longest,
Tom Rhodes has a fucking apartment now in Los Angeles.
Does when did
he get it?
Decided really recently.
He said,
I'm done.
I'm,
I'm going to stay here at the store where he was a hanging around the story,
you know that secret comics bar,
the little comics bar back.
Yeah.
Um,
there were all in comics are allowed to go there and hang out there and comics
friends.
He was,
we were hanging around back there and he's like,
dude,
I got apartment.
I hope.
What?
Yeah.
Well how long were you a renegade for?
He goes like 10 years.
For 10 years.
He came to my place last year and didn't have it,
so I know it's gotta be a reason.
Yeah.
He was staying in people's places.
He was a stem level.
The towels.
He's a great guy.
A great dude.
Yeah.
And he was up,
he also is one of those guys that a,
he's a world traveling comic.
Oh yeah.
You know,
he's done poor one.
We call in the next week and has done that kind of thing forever.
Forever.
Yeah.
I mean,
he's been doing standup for 25 years at least.
And Out of those 25 years,
he's been touring around the world for 15.
Yeah.
At least.
At least he used to have a show in Holland.
Yes.
Where was the late night show?
It was a late night show.
Was like a big time show and it was the something,
something she'll like some other guy's name starring Tom Rhodes.
It was like the like say if you like instead of like the Thompson girls show was
like the Jamie Vernon show starring Thompson Jura and like,
it was real weird.
Yeah.
And he was,
I heard it that,
you know,
he was like,
they're Letterman.
He was,
he did that for quite awhile.
He's a,
but he's,
he's decided now he wants to live in an apartment.
Yeah.
And he's had a wife for a while too.
He travels with his was great.
She,
she's great.
Yeah.
He,
um,
that mean he enjoyed that life.
You can live any way you want it,
man.
Do you know?
I think his mother's ours in time.
Everybody's got their own thing,
man.
For some people,
having a kid is the worst fucking idea on the planet.
I get that.
I totally understand that.
Yeah.
I think that's,
those are the people that are telling me,
are you out of your mind?
But there's a weird thing,
man.
And when people like this and dude,
when are you going to settle down now?
But yet you need to have a kid like,
whoa,
Whoa,
whoa.
It looks like you.
It's easy for you to say,
you know,
you're not a man until you have a kid.
You know you're not,
you're not mature.
You know?
You know,
like,
I think it's really obnoxious and gross to assume that everyone would want that
at even like at any point that like,
I think that it's totally legit.
There's somebody who's 50 60 70 years old,
never had kids and is totally fulfilled and happy.
Absolutely.
Why wouldn't they be?
You tell me you can't contribute unless you make another human being.
Yeah.
That's silly.
I mean,
what is your contribution in life?
Your contribution in life is how you affect other people.
Whether you influence them in a positive way,
whether you,
they think about you with love,
what they think about you with happiness,
the people that you've interacted with personally,
the people that you know,
that's what your legacy is.
And if you're a guy who thinks that having a kid is the end all be all,
but then your kid turns out to be fucked up.
Well what did you do dummy?
Yeah,
you're ruined your kid.
That was your contribution,
your contribution.
You fucked it up and he had one big project and you fucked it up.
Yup.
You're sitting there drawing decks.
No,
that's an old drawing.
But it's yours.
Truly old soul.
Yet our old,
yeah,
that's true.
But we were talking about the world's biggest tick,
so,
so you had a draw is inspiring.
You felt compelled.
Yeah.
Are you going to keep doing that once you have kid Tommy?
You got to think drawn dicks.
I think so,
but I'll just call them terrain.
Influence your kid by drawn techs.
I'm going to have a real tough time with,
uh,
being mature.
I feel like,
well,
I don't think you have to be.
Yeah.
Well I'll be very,
we already have a system in place where we're trying to,
uh,
we're going to do,
burps are one thumbs up,
but farts are two thumbs up because farts are fucking awesome.
What do you mean?
Like whenever,
whenever anyone farts around the kid,
what I'm going to go to with them about you and your wife just rip them in front
of each other.
Yeah,
sure.
But my belt,
has it been getting stronger?
They're better now.
You're working on it?
Yeah,
I think so.
I don't know.
I don't know more probiotics.
I just,
I just feel that I can,
I feel like I'm having them come up from the diaphragm now and they're just more
powerful,
you know.
Have you always farmed in front of your girlfriends?
Um,
not right away,
but eventually I'll,
I'd usually wait how many dates in,
oh,
it's a while.
I mean,
I make sure I'm in there.
I'm getting in there pretty often and then I do it.
I don't make sure you're fucked them good a while.
Yeah.
And it's like,
this is a regular thing here.
Come.
Do you know about Dara to tell you about the first time I fired in front of her?
No,
this is bold.
This is bold man.
We've been dating for for a little while probably like,
I dunno,
five,
six months or something and I'm at her place.
It's a Saturday morning.
I still remember him watching college football and I think she was making
breakfast or something.
And then life is great life.
I'm sitting on the couch.
Yeah,
I'm sitting on her couch wearing boxers,
watching TV and she comes and she sat next to me and I felt a fart come in and I
grabbed her arm and I took her hand and put it between my legs and I farted on
her hand,
first fart.
And I just remember her going like,
oh my God.
And she goes,
it smells like garbage.
It smells like garbage.
She kept saying that and she was like,
what the fuck?
And later,
like now she told me,
do you realize how crazy that was?
And I was like,
yeah,
I didn't realize it at the time.
If I was who I am now,
I would have fucking cut you off right then and there like that.
Really?
She says that like,
she was like,
clearly I was not in a good place
to stay with a guy that farted on my hand.
But it was funny.
Right.
It was really funny.
Yeah.
So why would she not?
I think she just,
I mean I think she was joking right in a way,
but she was just like,
like for a first fart to be on someone's hand worked out though.
Worked out well you knew she was the one I knew.
I knew that was,
that was essentially my proposal.
When did she fart in front of you first?
I mean afterwards.
I actually don't remember her first one,
but I'm getting a lot of them now.
It's made up for it.
Uh,
so she's been ripping some pregnancy farts are fucking powerful man.
Does that bum you out?
No,
never.
Cause,
cause the thing is like,
I'm not something
that's ever,
that has ever been like oo far.
Like,
it just doesn't,
it doesn't have that effect on the first girl that's ever farted in front of
you.
No.
God,
no.
So you just attract that kind of Gal.
I mean,
like I've been with girls that didn't obviously,
but yeah,
no,
if I dated you for awhile,
you fart.
It's okay.
No.
When you date girls for a while,
how do you know when it's time to unleash the hounds?
I mean,
it's different with every time it is and you got to feel it out.
But it's like,
I think it's a,
it's are you still in the,
like,
I'm trying to make an impression phase more.
Have you settled into like,
you know who you are,
who you are?
Yeah.
That's hard.
Right?
Do you not fart in front your wife?
If she accidentally walks in after I farted,
I claim it.
Yeah.
And does she fired her knee,
hips?
Uh,
she has,
she has more than once,
but I like it.
Let's say in bed.
She won't like,
like grab her ankles.
They go,
here we go.
I do some really obnoxious shit that's really obnoxious.
But like,
if you're laying in bed tonight and you're a whatever,
winding down,
you feel a Fart,
come do you get up and try to be polite.
You do.
We'll just kind of let it sneak out or just not only fart in front of my friends
like that.
So what would you do though?
Would you leave the room?
Uh,
yeah.
Most Lao or hold it in.
Wow.
Common courtesy is ridiculous.
And Tommy,
well,
I mean,
people don't want to smell their husbands farts.
I know,
but I lost if I thought in any way we keep it from blowing me.
Yeah.
Then then.
Well I guess it,
yeah,
I hear Ya.
It that way.
Yeah.
I'll hold my farts.
I'll hold my farts during sex to you.
Sure.
Yeah.
That's good.
But sometimes post-coital they,
they come out.
A friend of mine was a camera man.
Um,
he was camera man on whose camera?
Man on a TV show that I was on,
but he had also done some camera work on porn when he was starting out to,
you know,
to make money.
And he said,
ah,
there was just one guy.
It's like this big bulky bodybuilder guy who just would rip the most disgusting
far.
It's while he's fucking these grantees fucking while he's fucking him.
And because he just ate a lot of proteins.
Yeah.
And he was just farts unload these farts and these poor girls and they look,
they have to work.
Yeah.
Cause like,
like when you,
I guess when you're a guy and you're a porn star and he was this big muscular
black guy,
I guess first of all,
there's this thing where it's not matter of whether or not you're going to have
sex.
Yeah.
Like these girls are getting paid to have sex with you on camera.
It's not whether or not they're gonna want to do certain sexy things,
whether they're going to like it or not.
Like that's out the window now.
It's,
you're going to come,
I'm going to come in your face.
You got to come in their face.
I'm,
I'm gonna put it in your ass.
Like we already worked this out right in the contract.
Put it in your house.
We're going to ask the mouth,
I'm going to come in your face.
You're going to suck my balls,
I'm a jerk off in your hair.
Like it's all worked out.
Yeah.
So like this smile afterwards to snow like this,
this like
there's no romance to it.
Yeah.
There's no,
there's no special anciently no.
Well No,
definitely no intimacy because whatever you're doing,
you're doing in front of a gang of people.
There's a boom Mike hanging over the bed.
There's camera man.
There's a craft service table that you've been hitting up.
And uh,
I guess he's like,
I don't have to impress anybody.
I'm just going to fart
during sex is my line.
I've never done that.
I've never done that man.
So people don't have a problem with my,
I have a friend that,
that also was the camera guy for porns and not anymore,
but he told me,
he like,
he's like,
I go,
what?
What's like the grossest thing?
And he goes,
the grossest thing by far are the smells because he's like,
you know,
you're like,
I would come like underneath and be like kind of position under a guy's ass and
bald slap,
you know,
for that underneath shot.
And he's like,
just all of their smells.
I'm just like,
just inhaling them and then some will be like,
yeah,
get,
get another side of that.
And you go back down there like the worst part.
He said just smelling stuff.
Oh yeah.
It's pretty horrendous.
Wondering what happens if someone has a yeast infection and it's just stinks.
Do they just have to man up?
I think they probably go until someone's like,
I'm gonna Puke.
Or,
or like the guys,
like it won't get hard if I'm smelling this,
you know?
Oh God,
that's a,
that's a smell.
Did that yeast infection smell is nature's all alarm signal?
It is.
Yeah.
Let's talk about,
I know your favorite topic.
Ohio state,
Virginia Tech kicking off.
What are you talking about?
College football.
Oh,
big game.
you're talking because Jamie's here.
Yeah,
he's got a stupid fucking house and he's like,
he's all excited.
No,
no,
no.
It's,
it's just exciting.
That's all.
What do you,
what's excited about you?
Me excites you about it.
Right?
I feel the same way about college football that you do about fights.
Impossible.
I really,
I really do make sense.
Why?
Cause I get paid to talk about fights.
I'm a huge guy on ESPN.
You have never seen it.
I didn't know.
What did you do that they are offered you that Gig?
100%.
Really?
Yeah we'd be good at it.
Um,
I feel like I could do like the roundtable stuff right now.
I couldn't do like the commentating cause you do liquid Dennis Miller used to do
where you'd come in,
you know that's like [inaudible].
That's cool.
Wow.
That's horrible.
And I hate that role.
I like a two man commentating booth for,
for football or like your play about your color guy comment.
I like that setup of like somebody's telling you what's happening and the,
you know the analyst,
the analyst.
Once you really get into it and you see a really good analyst and in football
you really appreciate what the way they're highlighting things for you.
It's like what you do with like when you explain what,
what just happened,
right.
The lay person just goes like that guy's good.
Or like he fucked him up.
You know,
when you explain how it happens.
Right.
I love that in like,
I think Kirk
curb street who's an Ohio state guy is the best at it.
Like [inaudible] you saw basically a pass throne and a touchdown score and
you're like great paths.
But he explains that this guy,
the defensive play,
how the coverage broke down,
what the quarterback saw,
how it developed.
I love,
I love that aspect of it.
So you love the,
the strategic aspect of setting up the plays and seeing how something works.
Yeah,
I love that.
And I,
and I just love the environment.
I like college football the most.
Why do you like college the most?
I don't know man.
I think it's because I like,
you know,
I like the tradition.
I like the,
the rivalries,
they feel more genuine.
They feel like there's genuine hatred between teams.
Um,
you know,
the,
we're talking like a hundred year old programs,
you know,
like these or these or they've had a football team since like,
sometimes like 1898 shit like that.
You know,
we're like,
it's been there that long.
There's just,
there's just a passionate about it.
I Dunno.
I just,
I love being around it.
I love seeing the games.
That's crazy.
Um,
you've always been like this,
this is something you've always been excited about.
College football or was it something he says?
I was a kid,
says he only did what the gets me about college versus pro is that like you have
to follow all these young students that are playing football.
Right.
You have to know who they are.
You mean like if you're going to be like a super fan of the game.
I mean,
every year they're turning over,
right?
Oh yeah,
that's true.
Yeah.
Have like three years possibly.
Four years Max and then they're gone and you have new guys in it.
Could,
you know,
and I can tell like my level of,
because sometimes there's some,
there's certain years or,
or,
or a,
uh,
a certain number of years where I'll have a more laid back fandom to it or like,
I don't really know,
you know,
like the details like,
but you know,
a bunch of people.
Yeah,
I will.
But like,
I think this year I've been super busy.
Um,
you know,
I didn't pay as much attention definitely to like recruiting classes and stuff
that I've,
that I pay attention to before.
You know,
what,
why,
why college over like NFL?
You know,
I mean,
I like the stuff that I talked about,
like the,
the,
the passion stuff.
I love,
I feel like it's more,
it's more genuine.
there really are like,
there's a real passion for the game.
Part of it is because probably that a lot of those kids are trying to make it to
the NFL.
Oh,
for sure.
Yeah.
They're fucking killing themselves to make it.
Um,
you know,
like I said,
the rivalries feel like they,
they feel more joy,
more authentically,
just genuine and real.
I,
you know,
Ohio State,
Michigan,
um,
you know,
Florida state and Miami,
Georgia,
Florida,
like those kinds of games or just like,
or UCLA now I guess there'll be Ucla,
USC or USC,
Stanford,
the last few years.
You root for your college team that you went to school.
And now my,
my school was a fucking tiny d two school.
I just,
there's just programs that you grew up watching,
you know,
that you're just kind of crashed.
So alien to me.
Really?
Yeah.
It's so fun to me.
I don't know what it is,
man.
I just,
I love,
I love it.
I love the,
I love the environment.
You know?
I love it.
I hear people talking about like the NFL and like this,
this Tom Brady thing.
Just that people won't stop talking about that flat gate really fucking got some
legs and went,
never stopped.
Now he's been acquitted or they dropped the charges.
The federal judge threw out the suspension.
Basically decided that the commissioner couldn't punish him in the way that he
did.
One of the words,
it just,
you just ruled that you don't have the right to do that in this case,
Huh?
They can do that.
They just decide that you don't have the right to suspend somebody,
I guess.
I mean,
I,
I'd never seen it really go this far before.
What look like,
I mean,
you know,
I'm sure someone's going to explain it better than I can,
but like the commissioner said,
you know,
you're suspended for games and you guys are fine.
This and that for your party,
you know,
for this,
uh,
what I'm accusing you of,
which is the diff,
the flooding,
the footballs,
right,
right.
And then he appealed and then they went back and forth and then this federal
judge was gonna rule whether or not the suspension could be upheld or thrown
out.
And he'd ruled that it was like that the commissioner didn't have the authority
to do that even though he's suspended a lot of other people before for a lot of
other things.
And there's never been,
I've never seen it thrown out like that before.
Now how does that work?
Because they also took away their draft picks.
Right.
And find them a good amount of money so they have to pay that money back.
That's what,
I don't know.
I think they're trying to,
people were like,
well what are we going to get our drafts picked back?
Are we going to get the money back?
Like all those things I think are still up in the air.
But didn't that guy destroy his phone?
He did.
He did destroy one of his phones.
Yeah.
So they said that one of the big things is that like if it doesn't prove that he
didn't do anything wrong or that he didn't do what he's being accused of all
that,
the,
that the judgment is saying is that you can't suspend him for these four games.
Now what's the benefit of having a,
a softer ball?
Quits a,
it's about preference thing.
You know,
like some quarter,
every quarter back is different,
you know,
and like the uh,
a slightly deflated ball has it an easier grip as when some people argue,
you know,
they don't like it super full because it's really hard and sometimes it's a
harder grip.
So a slightly slightly deflated ball,
you know,
these guys,
it's like any sport,
like got,
you know,
the basketball guy might like his fresh pair of sneakers and make sure,
you see the guys,
they put the powder on it.
It's just like a personal preference thing.
So some guys like it,
that full grip and some guys like it slightly deflated.
What a massive distraction for people to like,
Oh yeah.
Many people over
the last year have been talking about deflated footballs.
Unbelievable.
I've never heard a single thing since.
Corked bats.
Remember the corked bats controversy during the,
Oh yeah,
sure.
The guys would drill holes in their bat and put Cork in the center of their bat
because apparently it gives more spring to the ball and you would get more
distance out of a home runs.
Yeah.
That's the last time I remember something being like,
I don't remember who it was,
but there was some famous player who broke a bat and then the,
the bad cork in it.
Yeah,
I remember everybody was like,
sure.
Rachel.
Outrageous.
Yeah,
no,
let me be part of it obviously is because he's,
you know,
he's Tom Brady.
So it's the,
the,
it's like going back to the lance thing.
It's like,
you know,
everyone's watching them there that they just won the Superbowl there.
You know,
he's the guy,
he's handsome.
He's Gary.
Dude.
Do you know how much money has fucking wife has made?
I've read a lot of different stats,
but apparently it's nothing short of $250 million or $400 million.
He apparently has made $150 million and she has made 400 million from modeling.
From looking pretty yeah.
For being,
yeah.
That's it.
I mean,
I don't have any idea what she sounds like when she talks.
She is kind of a deeper,
uh,
she loves the guy,
older bands,
shakes and wanting to families.
She has that Portuguese accent.
Wow.
But I mean,
stop and think about that.
You can make that much money as a supermodel.
Yeah.
That's more money than Bo Jackson never made his entire career.
It's really crazy.
400 million bucks dam and he's a,
he's a fucking one of the greatest quarterbacks of all time,
right?
Yeah.
Without a doubt.
He can't even come close to that.
It's not even,
it's not if,
if that's the real figure.
It's not even close quarterbacks,
man.
That's a tough gig because those dudes are all running at you trying to smash
you.
Yeah.
They say paint man.
He can't feel his fingers.
Yeah.
He can't feel his fingertips.
And he's been told a lot of times that it's never coming back.
Yeah.
And he had that neck injury where they were like,
you're never coming back.
And that's how much he loves playing.
That he,
you know,
thought through it.
What did they do for his neck?
They did that Regena King Shit.
That shit I had done on my knee had a crazy surgery done.
And then surgery.
Yeah,
he had surgery for sure.
So they're probably trimmed back the disc.
You know what they're doing now,
man.
They're giving people stem cell shots.
Really?
Oh Dude.
I got one of my shoulder.
Did you do that thing by the way,
when your kids were born,
where you like,
yes,
you did that right?
Yeah.
Banked the,
uh,
this embryotic but apparently there's a better way to do that now.
Um,
I think they use placenta now for that too.
They,
uh,
they used to use the uh,
the cord,
but now I believe they use placenta.
They gave us a whole kit and they were supposed to bring,
yeah,
yeah.
I'll look into it cause I think there's an another more effective way.
Really.
Yeah.
The uh,
the stem cells though that the,
they get from the placenta.
It's really fascinating stuff man.
They're a taking these,
I guess it's amniotic.
I guess that's the word.
[inaudible] and a,
they take these stem cells from prom placenta and they're shooting them in the
athletes and uh,
it's amazing it comes out of this,
it comes down to this tube where there's,
it's liquid nitrogens in it,
so smokes coming out of it cause it's frozen before they inject it in you.
It's really freaky.
Like this is some space age shit.
One shot and they shoot it in you within a week.
Within a week.
My shoulder fell amazing.
Really?
Yeah.
Now I'm five weeks in.
I keep waiting for it to hurt.
Like I'm doing all this working out.
I do doing rose and Chin ups and we keep waiting for it to fuck with me.
And it hasn't been fucking with me at all.
I was good back and he all this time,
everything's good,
man.
That's awesome.
I'm going to start shooting that stem cell shit everywhere.
Yeah.
Anything.
Anytime anything's wrong,
shoot it in there.
It's fucking see what's up.
They're going to have,
within a few years,
they're going to have these places where you're going to be able to go and
they're going to put young blood in your body.
This is going to happen.
This is the next thing,
because they've done all these studies that have shown with mice that when they
take young blood,
like the mice,
the young,
the blood of young mice,
and they put in the blood of old mice,
the mice,
their memory improves,
their athleticism improves.
Their body starts moving like a young mouse.
And then when they take the blood of old mice and they put it in young mice,
the young mice become old and tired.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
Fucking freaky.
Kind of amazing.
Someone was probably,
someone's gotta be doing that right now.
Dude in China guaranteed.
They probably have a bunch of fucking prisoners hooked up to machines and
they're sucking blood out of them,
like the Matrix,
you know,
and just pumping them right into their athletes.
Yeah.
They're also going to a,
they're doing these things called mio myostatin inhibitors.
And myostatin is what regulates your muscle size.
And they're doing that on Chinese athletes,
uh,
allegedly talking on that fuck with race when you have a billion people.
Yeah.
Just like it was plenty of people,
Bro.
That's our number one resources.
Humans experiment.
See how lucrative we can get.
Get liquid right now.
I gotta go.
I gotta go pee.
Go Pee.
We'll wrap this up.
We've already done three hours.
Holy Shit.
You're a fucking animal.
Tommy buttons.
When's your a Netflix special?
You just,
you just recorded one.
When is it airing?
It's coming out in January.
And then the last one,
which is hilarious.
Completely normal.
It's on Netflix now.
It's on Netflix right now.
Go take a peek.
You Fella.
Uh,
you could see Tommy Buns podcast.
It's called your mom's house with his lovely and talented wife,
Christina possessed ski.
You can catch Tommy on Twitter.
It's Tom Segura or on Instagram.
It's Segura Tom,
cause I guess there's some other Sigora Tom Sigora character out there.
Um,
and he's fucking awesome.
If he's coming to your town,
go see him,
check out his website,
all that jazz,
all that stuff's available on his Instagram and his Facebook and his Twitter.
That's it.
Um,
all right.
You fucks will be back tomorrow.
So,
uh,
tomorrow I'll see you then until then.
Be Nice to each other.
You've fucking savages.
Bye.
Okay.